there's a gateway in our minds and lead somewhere out there far beyond this hey so this is the taproot therapy collective podcast um on video uh and also on the audio so if we say something and you want to see the visual you can check out the youtube but have some exciting announcements um we have some good interviews coming up a lot of them got kicked back either due to writer's strike or people being sick so the podcast episodes have been a little bit slow um i hope to to get a lot of stuff coming out around christmas and we're always welcome um we always welcome like suggestions if you guys know of a guest that would be good or are a guest that you think would be good to
我们的思想中有一扇门，通向远方，超越这一切。嘿，这里是Taproot治疗集体播客，我们有视频版，也有音频版。所以如果我们说了什么，你想看视觉内容，可以去YouTube看看。我们有一些令人兴奋的公告，我们有一些很棒的采访即将推出，很多因为编剧罢工或人们生病而被推迟了，所以播客更新有点慢。我希望在圣诞节前后能发布很多内容，我们一直欢迎建议，如果你们认识适合的嘉宾，或者你们认为自己是合适的嘉宾，请发邮件给我。
me an email um but what's really exciting is we now have a new therapist and a new co-host to the podcast because there are you know five other therapists at taproot plus the qeg and neurostimulation and then everyone in our referral network but most of them um you know are just kind of busy and don't want to do a podcast it's's not up their alley. They'll like it. But Alice wanted to do that, which is awesome because we need another perspective and you guys don't have to listen to me as much. And I will have to write less think piece essays
但真正令人兴奋的是，我们现在有了一位新治疗师和一位新的播客联合主持人，因为Taproot还有其他五位治疗师，加上QEG和神经刺激，以及我们转诊网络中的所有人，但他们大多数人都很忙，不想做播客，这不适合他们。他们会喜欢的。但爱丽丝想做，这太棒了，因为我们需要另一种视角，你们也不必听我唠叨那么多了。我也不用写那么少思想文章了。
to read in my monotone voice. So I'll turn it over. Alice will be working at Taproot, hopefully in less than 90 days, but it will take at least that long to get a network with insurance so it'll be coming up you know probably after christmas but we're so happy to have you this it was kind of um synchronistic how we met i was uh you kind of came out of the blue as being a perfect thing for uh practice a little bit out there so um you want
用我单调的声音去读。所以我把它交给爱丽丝。爱丽丝将在Taproot工作，希望在90天内，但至少需要那么长时间才能加入保险网络，所以可能在圣诞节之后。但我们很高兴你能来，我们相遇的方式有点巧合，你就像是突然出现，非常适合我们的诊所，有点不可思议。所以，你想
to say a little bit about like your, your like practice as a therapist and, and you know, perspective. And we, I think today we're just going to have kind of a general conversation about the state of the industry and the way that the way that it works and the way that we do therapy. Yeah.
谈谈你作为治疗师的实践和视角吗？我想今天我们只是进行一场关于行业现状、运作方式以及我们进行治疗方式的常规对话。是的。
I've had a kind of a roundabout experience. I felt like I've been, you know, I'm a person who wanted to be a therapist since I was like in young years, you know, I had trauma around me that I didn't identify as trauma until way later, like had to hit grad school before I was like, okay, fine. My childhood was really traumatic. Trauma and intuition coming from the same part of the brain is like a thing that we've made a lot of hay with. You can't really tell the difference between a trauma response and intuition. But usually if you have childhood trauma, you know,
我的经历有点曲折。我觉得我是一个从年轻时就想成为治疗师的人，我周围有创伤，但我直到很久以后才意识到那是创伤，直到读研究生时我才意识到，好吧，好吧，我的童年真的很痛苦。创伤和直觉来自大脑的同一部分，这是我们经常讨论的话题。你真的无法区分创伤反应和直觉。但通常如果你有童年创伤，你知道，
your intuition is very heightened just kind of as a protective mechanism to try and see the future or understand people or keep yourself safe. But then that comes from trauma. So you usually are pretty effective if you deal with trauma. But that's the trick, right? We all think we have, and then the shadow is still there a little bit. So I try and wear mine on my sleeve so I know where it is in the room. Yeah, totally. It's very easy to, when you've been a victim of abuse and trauma, you suppress everything that you,
你的直觉非常敏锐，这只是一种保护机制，试图预见未来、了解他人或保护自己。但这源于创伤。所以如果你处理了创伤，你通常会很有效。但这就是诀窍，对吧？我们都认为我们处理好了，但阴影仍然存在一点。所以我尽量把它穿在袖子上，这样我就知道它在房间里的位置。是的，完全正确。当你成为虐待和创伤的受害者时，很容易压抑你所有的
all your opinions and all your, all your thoughts, because nobody's going to honor them. And yeah, you just kind of, like you said, you kind of start and you ignore your intuition or you follow your intuition,
观点和想法，因为没有人会尊重它们。是的，就像你说的，你开始忽视你的直觉，或者你跟随你的直觉，
but you use it for the wrong reasons. It's like, you are so attuned to to people um well i think that intuitive personality type like the magician like it's like it's not it's not immoral it's amoral i mean you can you can use it unconsciously and it's the same energy with the stand-up comedian or the con man or the grifter who's able to figure out who you are what are you running from how do i sell that to you to make it feel right they're using what you need and not what you want to control you whereas a therapist is giving you what you need what you want to help you but you know
但你用错了原因。你对人非常敏锐，嗯，我认为那种直觉型人格，比如魔术师，它不是不道德的，它是非道德的。我的意思是，你可以无意识地使用它，这和脱口秀演员、骗子或江湖骗子是一样的能量，他们能够弄清楚你是谁，你在逃避什么，我该如何把它卖给你让你感觉良好。他们利用你需要的而不是你想要的来控制你，而治疗师给你的是你需要的、你想要的来帮助你，但你知道
nurses social workers teachers they're all those high intuitive feeler types when they do the mbti or um you know the intuition is like really high it's just if it's unconscious it's trying to figure out how to sell you a rolex you know right um but the the person who's able to stand up as a stand-up comedian and be like all blankety blanks are like blankety blank you ever noticed that and you're like oh wow you should but that's true i mean they're seeing this systemic pattern that's not allowed and you know right right but i don't know yeah it's yeah it's like intuition gives you this it's a I don't know it connects the dots in your neural pathways advanced level that you are very high vibrational level that is hard to it's hard to intentionally try you can't intentionally train it very well it's just about like differentiating like you said a trauma response versus intuition like that's the only way to really train it i feel i had an
护士、社会工作者、老师，他们都是那些高直觉的感受型人格，当他们做MBTI测试时，直觉非常高。如果它是无意识的，它就在试图弄清楚如何卖给你一块劳力士，对吧？嗯，但是那个能够站出来做脱口秀演员的人，说“所有这些空白的人都像空白一样，你注意到了吗？”你会觉得“哦，哇，你应该……但这确实是真的。”我的意思是，他们看到了这种不被允许的系统性模式，对吧？但我不知道，是的，就像直觉给了你这个……我不知道，它在你的神经通路中连接了点，高级水平，你处于非常高的振动水平，很难有意地去训练它。你无法有意地很好地训练它，这只是关于区分，就像你说的，创伤反应与直觉，我觉得这是真正训练它的唯一方法。我曾经有一个
analyst tell me one time went way back when i was in therapy uh and she said something about it being really hard to see this stuff i just didn't want to i just kind of wanted to be normal um and she was like you can't you can't turn it off. You have to learn how to hold it, but you, you're, you can't, you can't turn that thing off, you know? Right. Um, which was hard to hear. Um, because it is hard to hold. Yeah. Yeah. But then it, I mean, it, I don't know, you hit, sometimes you just hit a complete rock bottom and then you realize it's your superpower. And that's kind of my, my story. I don't know. It felt like there was a lot of rock bottom in my life. And then, but the field always lit me up totally. Like, especially like in grad
分析师告诉我，很久以前我在接受治疗时，她说了一些关于很难看到这些东西的话，我只是不想，我只是想变得正常。她说：“你无法关掉它。你必须学会如何承受它，但你无法关掉它，你知道吗？”这很难听到，因为它确实很难承受。是的。但后来，我不知道，有时你会跌入谷底，然后你意识到这是你的超能力。这就是我的故事。我不知道，我觉得我生命中有很多谷底。但是这个领域总是让我感到振奋，特别是在研究生
school was very healing. And it's not a coincidence that I was also way away from far away from my family and my systems that I'm a part of. Um, and you know, the state where we're from, um, I went to school out in Colorado and it was, um,
学校时，那是非常治愈的。我离我的家人和我所属的系统很远，这并非巧合。嗯，你知道，我们来自的州，我在科罗拉多州上学，那是，
I went to university of Colorado. I did. Uh, I was at Boulder for my undergrad and, um, the counseling psychology program is in Denver. I wonder if you were in school with my cousins,
我去了科罗拉多大学。是的。我在博尔德读本科，咨询心理学项目在丹佛。我想知道你是否和我的表亲们一起上学，
they were out there at the same time. They weren't counseling. They were like welding and art. I'm an art professor out there now or a welding professor. And then another one works professionally as a like metal, metal artist. They fly around and do the chair cases and things, but yeah,
他们当时也在那里。他们不是学咨询的。他们是学焊接和艺术的。我现在那里是一位艺术教授或焊接教授。另一个专业是金属艺术家。他们到处飞，做椅子之类的东西，但是的，
they were all at the same time. Their last name is Blackstock so yeah yeah i always feel like i never know anybody that well it's a big place i mean i went to swanee so it's like technically 2 000 students but like you knew everybody even like even if you didn't meet them you you knew what kind of food they liked because you'd seen them in the cafeteria yeah at least like it funny was so tiny in such a weird weird place yeah well it was strange i mean at cu there's like maybe five when i was there there were maybe five people from alabama and it's like you just sort of knew you caught on to who the other people were from alex city which i thought was so random like
他们都在同一时间。他们的姓是Blackstock，所以是的，我总觉得我不太了解任何人，那是个很大的地方。我的意思是，我去了斯瓦尼，所以技术上只有2000名学生，但你认识每个人，即使你没见过他们，你也知道他们喜欢什么食物，因为你在食堂见过他们。是的，至少像那样，斯瓦尼太小了，在一个奇怪的地方。是的，这很奇怪，我的意思是，在科罗拉多大学，可能有五个……我在那里时，大约有五个来自阿拉巴马州的人，你只是会知道，你会发现谁是来自亚历克斯城的其他人，我觉得这太随机了，就像
how in the world did you end up at CU? And he would drive back for the Florida George for that Auburn Georgia game. Like every like two weeks into school drive all the way to Alabama to see that game and then drive all the way back. And it's like, the football is Mecca thing is, is pretty unique to Alabama. I mean, they like sports enough to like have a riot and burn down the city and other college towns. But there's not people in their 60s, like making a pilgrimage just to touch the grass
你到底是怎么去科罗拉多大学的？他会为了奥本大学对阵佐治亚大学的比赛开车回佛罗里达。就像每两周开学一次，一直开车回阿拉巴马看那场比赛，然后再开车回来。足球是麦加圣地，这在阿拉巴马州非常独特。我的意思是，他们喜欢运动，足以在其他大学城引发骚乱并烧毁城市。但没有60多岁的人，像朝圣一样只是为了触摸草地
on the quad, you know, I don't know. There is, it has more of a religious like element in Alabama for sure. Yeah, yeah, yeah. The religion is more about skiing and snowboarding. I don't think they're in the- It is, it. It really like when we I remember knowing people who were like, you know, oh, your dad's from Colorado. When are you going to take your daughter skiing? And I was like, she's like one and a half.
在方庭上，你知道，我不知道。在阿拉巴马州，这确实有一种宗教色彩。是的，是的，是的。宗教更多是关于滑雪和单板滑雪。我不认为他们在……确实，真的，当我记得认识那些人时，他们会说，“哦，你爸爸来自科罗拉多。你什么时候带你女儿去滑雪？”我说，她才一岁半。
I don't know. Like if I go skiing, she wants to go maybe. But and you would go on the ramp and there would be people who like that was from Colorado. Yeah, he was. Well,, my dad's family was military. So they moved everywhere. And then the last stop when I guess my grandmother and my granddad got divorced was Colorado. So she stayed there. So that was kind of the last home he had, I guess, but he was in Huntsville and he was everywhere.
我不知道。如果我去滑雪，她可能想去。但你会去坡道上，那里会有来自科罗拉多的人。是的，他是。好吧，我爸爸的家人是军人。所以他们到处搬家。当我的祖母和祖父离婚时，最后一站是科罗拉多。所以她留在了那里。我想那是他拥有的最后一个家，但他曾在亨茨维尔，他到处都是。
Oh, okay. Um, so you never, as soon as he met, made friends and have to leave. And I think, you know, it was kind of a hard way to grow up. Um, but then his brother stayed out there and his brother recently passed away he's really nice guy he had a construction company and so they he has three boys and wow those are my cousins yeah sorry to interrupt i did not know that yeah well the what is it the um she said something i wanted to jump back to we were talking about skiing and snowboarding being like yeah we when i even as a kid i'd go up there and there's people that like literally had like a one and a half year old baby
哦，好的。所以你从来没有，一旦他交了朋友就得离开。我认为，这是一种艰难的成长方式。但后来他的兄弟留在了那里，他的兄弟最近去世了，他是个非常好的人，他有一家建筑公司，他有三个儿子，哇，那是我的表亲。是的，抱歉打断你，我不知道。是的，好吧，她说的我想跳回到我们谈论滑雪和单板滑雪的时候，是的，即使我还是个孩子，我也会去那里，有些人真的有一个一岁半的婴儿
in a suspender thing so you had to hold it because it can't do anything you know in skis like in between their legs like getting them ready for that it was like they they really they really like it they like live to do it so yeah the little ones are better like they and they don't use um the you know the pole when you're really little so they're just like buzzing around on their skin yeah grown-ups yeah my dad always wanted to take ski trips and you know we were all from alabama didn't know how to do it so oh yeah i mean i passingly know how to but but I'm not going to win any contests. Yeah, I can talk about it, but I really didn't go that much. And yeah, you have to get up really early and it's so cold.
在背带里，所以你必须抱着它，因为它什么都做不了，你知道，在滑雪板上，就像在他们的腿之间，就像为那做好准备，他们真的很喜欢它，他们活着就是为了做那个，所以是的，小家伙们更好，他们不使用……你知道，当你很小的时候不用杆子，所以他们只是在滑雪板上嗡嗡作响。是的，成年人，是的，我爸爸总是想去滑雪旅行，你知道我们都来自阿拉巴马州，不知道怎么做，所以哦是的，我的意思是，我大概知道怎么做，但我不会赢得任何比赛。是的，我可以谈论它，但我真的去得不多。而且是的，你必须起得很早，而且太冷了。
It's really expensive. Ski lifts are very anxiety provoking. Yeah. The ski lifts were like the most fun part to me, but the waiting four hours to be on the ski lift was not um you know if four in the morning yeah so i guess you know you're coming into our practice and and we kind of discovered that we were kind of in the same world our practice is a little bit niche for the area maybe for everywhere but um can you say a little bit about like your style and kind of what brought you into it and and the things that you've used because it sounds like
这真的很贵。滑雪缆车非常让人焦虑。是的。滑雪缆车对我来说是最有趣的部分，但等待四个小时才能坐上滑雪缆车并不是……你知道，凌晨四点。所以我想，你知道，你来到我们的诊所，我们发现我们处于同一个世界，我们的诊所对这个地区来说有点小众，也许对任何地方都是，但你能谈谈你的风格以及是什么把你带入这个领域的吗？因为听起来
and especially going back to your bio like some of the older stuff from when you were in private practice you know uh before is like still there and it looks like kind of what happened to you happened to or kind of what happened to me happened to you where you go into there you come out of grad school and you're like i'm gonna be this kind of therapist and then you know two months in you're like wait a minute this doesn't work i don't like that and then you end up doing you know something that you never really would have thought just because you want to help people and it's working you end up going in this new direction yeah um it's like the clients in your community are different you know like the community of people that i would have been working with in colorado are very different than the community here. So it's, it's, I don't know, it's interesting,
特别是回到你的简历，你私人执业时的一些旧东西，你知道，之前的东西还在那里，看起来就像发生在我身上的事情也发生在你身上，你进入研究生院，你想成为那种治疗师，然后两个月后，你觉得“等一下，这行不通，我不喜欢那样”，然后你最终做了一些你从未想过的事情，只是因为你想帮助别人，而且它奏效了，你最终朝着这个新方向发展。是的，就像你社区里的客户不同，你知道，我在科罗拉多州工作的人群与这里的人群非常不同。所以，这很有趣，
like the groups of people who gravitate towards therapy, for example, kind of, and like, I was doing very purist family and couples work. And I even were using Gottman at that point, the Gottman method method gotman and emotionally focused therapy like susan susan johnson um sue johnson i like eft i i don't i've never seen the tests um i've known people that did it but gotman i was always kind of curious i'd always wondered what you thought of that because i mean it for people unfamiliar it's a and correct me where i'm wrong because i don't do it, but it's like a test basically,
比如那些倾向于治疗的人群，例如，我当时在做非常纯粹的家庭和夫妻工作。我甚至在那时使用了戈特曼方法，戈特曼方法和以情绪为中心的治疗，比如苏珊·约翰逊，苏·约翰逊。我喜欢EFT，我从来没见过测试，我认识做过的人，但我一直对戈特曼很好奇，我一直想知道你怎么看它，因为我的意思是，对于不熟悉的人来说，它是一个测试，基本上，
which is pretty good for the Gobbin Institute. I imagine it's lucrative, but the couple actually does a test that you did. They have to pay the Institute for, and then they send the results to the patients and the therapists. And it's like, this is where you're good in the relationship. This is where you need work.
这对戈特曼研究所来说相当不错。我想这很赚钱，但夫妻实际上做了你做的测试。他们必须向研究所付费，然后他们将结果发送给病人和治疗师。就像，这是你在关系中做得好的地方。这是你需要努力的地方。
Yeah. I didn't experience that way. Um, the Gobbin stuff is great. I, they they'll give they give you a huge book it's it's extremely evidence-based which is like very hard evidence-based where he's been in a lot like has a lab where couples come and stay there yeah for like a couple weeks or and they and he's been doing this for like 40 years where and they code every single interaction of the couples in the in like a set up apartment and like they have a breakfast room and everything and they record everything and um and so they
是的。我没有那种体验。戈特曼的东西很棒。他们会给你一本巨大的书，它非常有实证基础，是非常硬的实证基础，他在那里有一个实验室，夫妻们来那里住上几周，他已经做了40年了，他们对夫妻在公寓里的每一次互动进行编码，他们有早餐室等等，他们记录一切，所以他们
have all these statistics about reality tv science reality tv they have all these um this amazing statistics and relational work about different behaviors and what predicts divorce um in married couples you can predict like within a 96 uh accuracy which couples are going to still be together in five years versus which are not without intervention and if you intervene and use so there are a lot of assessments that you can use for government do it you can i never did it where you had to send something in so everyone that i've ever known in this area that did it that's what they did is the patient came in and then they made the patient like log on to the website. I'm not knocking it. I'm just saying and like pay the institute.
有所有关于现实电视科学的统计数据，他们有所有这些关于不同行为的惊人统计数据和关系工作，以及什么预测离婚，在已婚夫妇中，你可以预测，有96%的准确率，哪些夫妻在五年后还会在一起，哪些不会，无需干预。如果你干预并使用……所以有很多评估你可以使用，我从来没有做过必须寄回东西的。所以在这个地区我认识的每一个做过的人，他们就是这样做的，病人进来，然后他们让病人登录网站。我不是在批评它。我只是说，像支付研究所。
I don't know what 50 bucks or something. And then they did the test in the first session. And then when the results came back, they were like, okay, this is what we're working on. But that's the only way I'd ever encountered it. Schema therapy is kind of like that too. In the schema institute,, you do a test, but they're in control of the test. You can't just buy the test and apply it yourself.
我不知道，50美元左右。然后他们在第一次会议中做了测试。当结果回来时，他们说，好吧，这就是我们要努力的方向。但这是我遇到它的唯一方式。图式治疗也差不多。在图式研究所，你做一个测试，但他们控制测试。你不能只是买测试并自己应用它。
You have to kind of pay the Institute. Well, with the God of, if I have like a stack of assessments like this thick and I put, I myself put, then you're supposed to be able to use them for anybody. So, and it's not like a big,
你必须支付研究所。好吧，对于戈特曼，如果我有一叠像这么厚的评估，我亲自放，你应该能够把它们用于任何人。所以，它不像一个大的，
it's not like one big test. There's like a page that evaluates this page that evaluates that and um and it's more like checklists that you then there's not like they're not coded like there's not a um you don't get a score on it you just it's all intuitively interpreted at least when i did it but i tried i trained like 15 years ago so maybe they're i mean that's a they have a very good brand um and their stuff is really solid like i love their stuff not it doesn't have a it doesn't have like a work perspective on couples it's generalizable to any any population the same sex couples like it is um yeah i like it a lot and i found that this is one thing that people say and i found also to be true is that um kind of the the um the stereotypical like man who gets dragged to
它不像一个大测试。有一页评估这个，一页评估那个，它更像是清单，然后没有……它们没有被编码，没有分数，你只是直观地解释它，至少我做的时候是这样，但我15年前接受过培训，所以也许他们……我的意思是，他们有一个非常好的品牌，他们的东西真的很扎实，我喜欢他们的东西，它没有关于夫妻的工作视角，它适用于任何人群，同性伴侣，是的，我非常喜欢它，我发现这是一件人们说的事情，我也发现是真的，那就是
couples therapy by his partner um that sort of person loves the Gottman stuff because it's very concrete and like is able to put into context these concepts that a lot of people who are way more like concrete think black and white thinkers don't it's much easier to grasp it's like oh okay here's some actual tools and here's you know what I'm actually doing that's causing this this thing i mean it gives you some action oriented work on but yeah it's kind of just informs my perspective i was working for a while where i was doing where i did the assessments and then it just kind of got it gets clunky to me like that's that's part of generally therapists start with tons of assessments like everyone i knew right out of school including me
那种刻板印象，比如被伴侣拖到夫妻治疗中的男人，那种人喜欢戈特曼的东西，因为它非常具体，能够将这些概念置于语境中，很多像具体思维、黑白思维的人，它更容易掌握，就像“哦，好的，这里有一些实际的工具，这里是你实际上正在做的导致这件事的事情”。我的意思是，它给你一些以行动为导向的工作，但是的，它只是丰富了我的视角。我工作了一段时间，我做了评估，然后它对我来说变得笨拙了，这通常是治疗师从大量评估开始的，就像我刚出校门认识的每个人，包括我
it was like oh suicide screener this this this this and then you've done it enough times it's kind of in your head and you you do it for court or for liability or for you know the patient's request but you kind of learn the assessment enough that you're not just covering up patients with paper right in my experience i mean not yeah that not the right way to do it and I this is another like I really found that like in school we learned that we were really taught everything over us like once we got into practice everything was over a solution focused kind of framework where we're all like we could be doing something like narrative therapy which is very very deep and um wordy and takes a long time narrative therapy um a lot of art and stickers and billboards and books and yarn and narrative therapy no i don't
就像“哦，自杀筛查，这个，这个，这个”，然后你做得足够多了，它就在你的脑子里了，你为了法庭或责任，或者为了病人的要求而做，但你学会了评估，以至于你不仅仅是用纸覆盖病人，对吧？在我的经验中，我的意思是，不是那种做它的正确方式。这是另一个，我真的发现，在学校里我们学到的一切，一旦我们进入实践，一切都是以解决方案为中心的框架，我们都像……我们可以做一些叙事治疗，这非常非常深刻，而且冗长，需要很长时间。叙事治疗，很多艺术、贴纸、广告牌、书和纱线，叙事治疗，不，我不
use yarn but just like like really focusing on people's language and helping them restory their memories and things like that. But with the assessment, I just always felt like, you know, it's really the we have learned that it's people get the effect of therapy within 10 to 12 sessions. And then after that, it's not it's no like the results show it's no longer really effective. I don't think that now I'm like, okay, that's. Cognitive therapy, the patient probably absorbs everything that you can say on the script. Yeah. 20 sessions, I would think. But it's like you work with somebody who's dissociating and it can take like 15 sessions for you to see for, you know, their parts to to be comfortable even like kind of creeping out you
使用纱线，只是像真正关注人们的语言，帮助他们重构记忆之类的事情。但对于评估，我总是觉得，你知道，我们已经了解到人们在10到12次会议内获得治疗效果。在那之后，结果显示它不再真正有效。我现在不这么认为，我想，好吧，那是。认知治疗，病人可能吸收了你能在脚本上说的所有东西。是的，20次会议，我想。但就像你和解离的人一起工作，可能需要15次会议才能看到，你知道，他们的部分感到舒适，甚至像爬出来，你
know when you're a standard yeah because the more vulnerable and kind of repressed parts don't even feel safe for a long time yeah it's really about you know the relationship but then other clients i like i really tried not to practice in a way where I was expecting people to just keep coming indefinitely. Like I was trying to help people get better and, and move on. And so sometimes it just really would feel like, okay, I feel like they've gotten the benefit of this work right now where they are within like three sessions or within. Yeah. It is wild that you say this one thing sometimes and it's like you're done you know yeah and then other times it doesn't work like that but i mean i think we both agree on like push the
知道当你是一个标准……是的，因为更脆弱和被压抑的部分在很长一段时间内甚至感觉不到安全。是的，这真的是关于关系，但其他客户，我真的尽量不以那种我期望人们无限期地继续来的方式进行实践。我试图帮助人们变得更好，然后继续前进。所以有时它真的会感觉，好吧，我觉得他们现在已经从这项工作中获得了好处，在三次会议内或之内。是的，你说这句话有时很疯狂，就像你完成了，你知道，是的，有时它不是那样工作的，但我的意思是，我认为我们都同意，把
patient into the bad place teach them to be independent to not run from it you know that like and and then go forward and be careful you know you're not pushing people into things they're not ready for but the goal of therapy is really to internalize your own wisdom and you you know sometimes as a parent sometimes as a shaman sometimes as a friend or just a kind of voice of other language you internalize the therapist's voice in your head and you decide which parts are you and which parts are not because you know i'm different from my patients they're not supposed to just believe everything i believe or think everything i think and then it's there and you're independent and you're, you're good.
病人推向糟糕的地方，教他们独立，不要逃避它，你知道，然后继续前进，小心，你没有把人们推向他们还没准备好的事情，但治疗的目标真的是内化你自己的智慧，你，你知道，有时作为父母，有时作为萨满，有时作为朋友，或者只是另一种语言的声音，你内化了治疗师在你脑海中的声音，你决定哪些部分是你，哪些部分不是，因为你知道，我和我的病人不同，他们不应该只是相信我所相信的一切，或思考我所思考的一切，然后它就在那里，你是独立的，你是好的。
Yeah. Yeah, totally. I mean, that's, yeah, I, that's,
是的。是的，完全正确。我的意思是，那是，是的，我，那是，
that's where it's like the assessments, like when using your first few sessions to throw assessments at people, you, you lose, it's like the critical period of, you lose patience. Yeah the critical period of yeah you lose patience yeah you lose the you lose the possibility of connecting with them in the way that um yeah so i don't know the school in the 90s probably has a trauma response to scan
那就是评估，就像在最初的几次会议中使用评估来扔给人们，你，你失去了，就像关键时期，你失去了耐心。是的，关键时期，是的，你失去了耐心，是的，你失去了，你失去了以那种方式与他们联系的可能性，嗯，是的，所以我不知道90年代的学校可能对扫描有创伤反应。
i would imagine yeah i sure do i sure do. I sure do. journals all the time and read this stuff. But I also understand the role that research has. And I, you know, I think both of our criticism is that sometimes people use to turn off their brain. Like you're saying that they told you in school, 12 sessions of therapy, anything beyond that, you're not getting anything out of. Well, I believe that, but that's based on when I'm doing psychoeducation and ego management strategies and cognitive therapy, you absorbed all that by 12 to 15 sessions. Right. Right. So when you're, so the research can measure that because that's objective, you know, that can be turned into a number right so when you're so the research can measure that because that's objective you know that can be turned into a number but when you start saying like well there's a vulnerable part of the client where i saw another side of them where they you
我想是的，我确实有，我确实有。我确实有。一直写日记，读这些东西。但我也理解研究的作用。而且我，你知道，我认为我们俩的批评是，有时人们用它来关掉他们的大脑。就像你说他们在学校告诉你的，12次治疗，超过这个，你就得不到任何东西。好吧，我相信这一点，但那是基于我在做心理教育和自我管理策略以及认知治疗时，你在12到15次会议内吸收了所有这些。对，对。所以当你，所以研究可以衡量这一点，因为那是客观的，你知道，那可以变成一个数字，对吧？所以当你，所以研究可以衡量这一点，因为那是客观的，你知道，那可以变成一个数字，但当你开始说，好吧，有一个客户的脆弱部分，我看到了他们的另一面，你
can't turn that into a number but that's still part of therapy you know so i i want to make room for that in therapy too that isn't something that that research can do a case study can do that you know right um and that's kind of why my criticism of the way that we do academics now is that we don't even really read research journals to be read by people we read them to make careers we write them to be cited by because your impact factor my my pay as a professor and my salary is based on my impact factor like but the impact factors for the journal what's the i forget the i forget what the metric is but basically the more somebody cites your papers right yeah the number is
不能把它变成一个数字，但这仍然是治疗的一部分，你知道，所以我，我想在治疗中也为那留出空间，这不是研究能做到的，案例研究可以做到，你知道，对，嗯，这就是为什么我批评我们现在做学术的方式，我们甚至不真正阅读研究期刊供人们阅读，我们阅读它们是为了建立职业生涯，我们写它们是为了被引用，因为你的影响因子，我作为教授的薪水和我的工资是基于我的影响因子，但是期刊的影响因子，是什么……我忘了，我忘了指标是什么，但基本上，别人引用你的论文越多，对吧？是的，数字是
which you know kind of makes sense but what happens is no one writes a case study because not everyone's going to cite that what they're going to do is be like we extrapolated 10 different sets of data and then controlled them for different variables and you cite everything and you have this giant uh what do they call them like you know analytical uh review of multiple studies so then more studies have to cite that but you read them and it's like this is not helping anyone do therapy better this is written for someone to cite it it's when you it's like when you land on those pages on the internet that you're like oh this was written for google to read it's not written for a human to read it It's being like, you, therapist area, are you hungry?
这（你知道，有点道理），但发生的事情是，没有人写案例研究，因为不是每个人都会引用那个。他们要做的是，“我们推断了10组不同的数据，然后为不同的变量控制了它们”，你引用一切，你有这个巨大的……他们称之为什么，你知道，多项研究的分析性回顾，所以更多的研究必须引用那个。但你读了它们，就像“这并没有帮助任何人更好地进行治疗，这是为了让人引用它而写的”。这就像当你登陆互联网上的那些页面时，你会觉得“哦，这是为谷歌阅读而写的，不是为人类阅读而写的”。它就像，“你，治疗师区域，你饿吗？”
But, you know, just looks like an AI road. Yeah, and it's kind of interesting, like, in the broader public sphere that there is this, you know, people who don't know what the words mean are declaring that they want evidence on, you know, where's your evidence? Where's your peer reviewed papers to back up this claim like people who don't actually know it's a concept you can't peer review but it's still kind of intuitive and useful but nobody has access to like okay there's you can look up research on google but it is not the same as being in a university library and
但是，你知道，看起来就像AI之路。是的，这很有趣，在更广泛的公共领域，有这个，你知道，不知道这些词是什么意思的人宣称他们想要证据，你知道，“你的证据在哪里？你的同行评审论文在哪里支持这个说法？”像那些实际上不知道这是一个无法同行评审的概念的人，但它仍然是直观和有用的，但没有人能获得，比如，好吧，你可以在谷歌上查找研究，但这与在大学图书馆里不同，而且
having all the databases like there's the real research is access through people who are in academia. It's like, you can't even be a person walking around. Yeah. Those subscriptions are $800 a month. If you want to get a host or something. I mean, we, we paid to access some of them for a while. Exactly. And you can't just like, I've tried, like,
拥有所有数据库，比如真正的研究是通过在学术界的人获得的。就像，你甚至不能成为一个走来走去的人。是的，那些订阅费是每月800美元。如果你想找个主持人什么的。我的意思是，我们，我们付钱访问了其中一些一段时间。完全正确。而且你不能只是像，我试过，像，
you can't just join a university library. Like you can't, there's not an option to do that can't just like, I've tried, like, you can't just join a university library. Like you can't, there's not an option to do that as far as like, even my, even see, see you like my, I was like, well, as an alum, shouldn't they let me be able to be a library member? No. A lot of people will teach a class if they want to keep a foot in the door with research. They'll just teach one college class like as an adjunct or something. Yeah. Just to get access to the library. Because once you have that email, you can log on to the university. But if you don't, you can't.
你不能只是加入大学图书馆。就像你不能，没有选项可以做到，我试过，像，你不能只是加入大学图书馆。就像你不能，没有选项可以做到，就我而言，甚至我的，甚至科罗拉多大学，我的，我当时想，好吧，作为校友，他们不应该让我成为图书馆会员吗？不。很多人如果想在研究中保持一席之地，就会教一门课。他们只是教一门大学课程，作为兼职什么的。是的。只是为了获得图书馆的访问权限。因为一旦你有了那个电子邮件，你就可以登录大学。但如果你没有，你就不能。
Well, yeah, totally. And it's, it's, oh, I just lost my, oh, and I mean in you know so there's the effect of people need to write research in order to get tenure and those types of you're talking about and then it's like you realize that it's like the only things that get funding are the things that schools want to fund which is pretty trendy too i mean trendy is as science is as trendy as like english or something you know where it's like braided narrative is now in oh now somatic now now somatics are the thing that you do in the english department you know like that it changes and science does the same thing like it's it's it just is kind of bad chasing yeah um in a way
好吧，是的，完全正确。而且，它是，哦，我刚失去了我的，哦，我的意思是，你知道，所以人们需要写研究才能获得终身教职，以及你谈论的那些类型，然后你意识到，唯一获得资助的东西是学校想要资助的东西，这也相当时髦，我的意思是，科学和英语或什么东西一样时髦，你知道，就像编织叙事现在很流行，哦，现在躯体，现在躯体是你在这个英语系做的事情，你知道，它会改变，科学也做同样的事情，就像它，它只是有点追逐坏事，是的，嗯，以一种
it's funded not in in the you know, you know, the discipline itself, if it was followed, you know, scientifically. Yeah. It's like the powers that be decide what the perspective of the school is going to be. And then you identify somebody who will do research to back up that opinion and then you fund or, you know, and I mean, and it's really also based on who are the people who are paying, who are giving money to the school, the big corporations. And that dictates what studies are funded and not. And we tend to only research things that we already think we know the answer to in order to prove that. And then when it proves us wrong, we don't change. Like, I mean, evidence, Exhibit A is the DARE program, right?
它被资助的方式，而不是在（你知道，你知道，学科本身），如果它被遵循，（你知道，科学地）。是的。就像当权者决定学校的视角将是什么。然后你确定一个会做研究来支持那个观点的人，然后你资助，或者，你知道，我的意思是，它也确实基于谁是那些付钱的人，谁给学校钱，大公司。这决定了哪些研究被资助，哪些不被资助。而且我们倾向于只研究我们已经认为知道答案的东西，以便证明这一点。然后当它证明我们错了时，我们不会改变。就像，我的意思是，证据，证据A是DARE项目，对吧？
Like you have Nancy Reagan being like, we're on drugs, whatever, instead of, you know, education or something that was, you know, kind of useful or funding or kind of meeting the needs of these communities. Let's just go, you know, scare kids straight with DARE. And then they kind of tried to make DARE different later on.
就像你有南希·里根说，“我们反对毒品，无论如何”，而不是，你知道，教育或某种（你知道，有点用处）的东西，或者资助，或者满足这些社区的需求。让我们只是去，你知道，用DARE吓唬孩子。然后他们后来试图让DARE变得不同。
But whatever change they made, we researched DARE for a decade. It made kids do more drugs. If you took a school that didn't have a DARE program and then you did a DARE program, have a dare program and then you did a dare program drug use went up and then you could compare that to and there was no way around it i mean the research said that and they kept being like oh maybe we need to control for that no
但无论他们做了什么改变，我们研究了DARE十年。它让孩子们吸了更多的毒品。如果你找一个没有DARE项目的学校，然后你做了一个DARE项目，有一个DARE项目，然后你做了一个DARE项目，毒品使用量上升了，然后你可以把它与……比较，而且没有办法绕过它，我的意思是研究说了这一点，他们一直说，“哦，也许我们需要控制那个”，不
like the dare program didn't work it made kids do drugs did we quit doing the dare program no like because we we kept throwing more money at research to try and get the study to say that actually it worked and it just didn't work. Yeah. You get really disillusioned because it's like, then you, you learn that we know best practice for all these things, like in education, for example,
像DARE项目没有用，它让孩子们吸毒，我们停止做DARE项目了吗？不，因为我们继续向研究投入更多资金，试图让研究说它实际上有效，但它就是没用。是的。你变得非常幻灭，因为就像，然后你，你了解到我们知道所有这些事情的最佳实践，比如在教育中，例如，
and then you figure out, well, it's nobody who is a teacher or in education really gets to make the calls about what they study in schools. You know, education is the worst for the way that researchers use that like that like they'll they'll come into education and they'll like every bit of data that we have going back to the beginning of research says even if the
然后你发现，好吧，没有人是老师或在教育领域的人真正能决定他们在学校学习什么。你知道，教育是最糟糕的，因为研究人员使用它的方式，就像他们会进入教育领域，他们会像我们拥有的每一位数据，追溯到研究开始，说即使
teacher is not good even if the teacher's incompetent if the classroom is smaller the kids will do better just hire more teachers pay teachers and and that's never what they've done all the research has said that it works a hundred times what they do is they go in and they're like oh well pearson hall has this information technology uh communications education platform and it's two points better than the the one by epson that's you know play-d. So we need to switch to the Blackboard program. Okay, you're talking about these incremental tiny gains for millions and millions and millions of dollars where you know that it's going to be 65% more effective if you just hire teachers
老师不好，即使老师不称职，如果教室更小，孩子们会做得更好，只是雇佣更多的老师，支付老师，而这从来不是他们所做的。所有的研究都说它有效了一百次，他们所做的是他们进去，他们就像，“哦，好吧，Pearson Hall有这个信息技术通信教育平台，它比Epson的那个好两点，那是（你知道，Play-D）。”所以我们需要切换到Blackboard程序。好吧，你谈论的是数百万数百万美元的这些增量微小收益，你知道，如果你只是雇佣老师，它会有效65%
and you don't have 35 kids in a classroom, you know? But they're not doing research to figure out what works. They're doing research to figure out how to justify the payments to these giant corporations. And I mean, this isn't to knock on research. I mean, studying cause and effect is inherently helpful. We're talking about what the ethics outside of the study. And like in graduate school, you learn, oh, the ethics of the study, all this, whatever.
而且你的教室里没有35个孩子，你知道吗？但他们不是在做研究来找出什么有效。他们是在做研究来找出如何证明对这些大公司的付款是合理的。我的意思是，这不是为了抨击研究。我的意思是，研究因果关系本质上是有帮助的。我们谈论的是研究之外的伦理。就像在研究生院，你学习，哦，研究的伦理，所有这些，无论什么。
They're talking about inside the study, but the ethics of who funded it, how's it used, where is it coming from? We just turn our brains off and act like anything that comes out of these journals is magic and I just it's strange I don't mean I like research for what it is but it is what it is you know right right yeah and I was I went through the whole application process for PhDs and PsyDs, which went fine. But it was just like the experience of that where it's just like you're looking, you have to look at, look through the professors, research, like the professors who work in each individual program, look at what their research
他们谈论的是研究内部，但谁资助它的伦理，它是如何使用的，它来自哪里？我们只是关掉我们的大脑，表现得好像从这些期刊出来的任何东西都是魔法，我只是……这很奇怪，我不意味着我喜欢研究本身，但它就是它，你知道，对，对，是的，我经历了博士和心理学博士的整个申请过程，这很顺利。但这就像那种经历，就像你在看，你必须看，看教授，研究，就像在每个单独项目中工作的教授，看他们的研究
background is, and find someone who sounds like they might match up with what you want to study so it's like you have to find somebody in the country who wants to study the same thing as you're interested in which by the way there's nobody as far for whatever it was that i was like so then it ends up that you tailor all of your applications to okay well that guy has interest in his bio but i have to write a completely different essay saying i want to do this kind of research for this program. And well, and just the amount of abuse and corruption in those systems where people, you know, you won. I mean, just the idea that you have to work for free, I don't think is right. And then to or, you know, not even work for free, you're paying to work, you're doing work for these guys. But then the amount of professors that you know financially sexually
背景是什么，找到一个听起来可能与你想研究的内容相匹配的人，所以就像你必须在全国范围内找到一个想研究和你感兴趣的东西一样的人，顺便说一句，没有，就我当时的情况而言，所以最终你把你所有的申请都量身定制为“好吧，那个人在他的简历中有兴趣，但我必须写一篇完全不同的文章，说我想为这个项目做这种研究。”而且，仅仅是那些系统中的虐待和腐败数量，人们，你知道，你赢了。我的意思是，仅仅是你必须免费工作这个想法，我不认为是对的。然后去，或者，你知道，甚至不是免费工作，你是在付钱工作，你在为这些人做工作。但随后你知道的教授数量，经济上，性上
i mean there's just you see all this that system the power is so lopsided that even if it's not that everybody is bad but you're it's just enabling the worst behavior right and and and and just the competitiveness of it you know that you're never safe because all these people you know more than anyone else in the world about this teeny tiny little area safe because all these people you know more than anyone else in the world about this teeny tiny little area and all the other people who know as much as you do about that teeny tiny little area are fighting for your job right i mean that's that just seems lonely and sad i don't know um i mean and it's not a huge it's not like everywhere in academia is like that but it is a trend that i think you look at the 70s go ahead i said i don't know it's kind of like everywhere is like that but
我的意思是，你看到的整个系统，权力是如此不平衡，即使不是每个人都是坏人，但它确实在助长最糟糕的行为，而且那种竞争感，你知道你永远没有安全感，因为所有这些人，你比世界上任何人都更了解这个极其微小的领域，而所有其他和你一样了解这个微小领域的人都在争夺你的工作，对吧？我的意思是，这看起来既孤独又悲哀，我不知道，我的意思是，这并不是说学术界的每个地方都是这样，但这是一种趋势，我想你看看70年代，你说吧，我说我不知道，这有点像到处都是这样，但是
well and what what gets me though when you're saying like using research for what it is sometimes you know intuitive concepts and soft sciences are inevitable and even in hard sciences like intuitive concepts and metaphors are used right but it's like you get so much flack because like i'll write something and then somebody will send me an email and be like well you shouldn't have a license because you said the unconscious and the unconscious is not evidence-based it's like what does that mean like you know you guys said that the unconscious doesn't exist we're just the ego that's all we are and now you're going back and being like well car, Carl Jung was still wrong.
嗯，但让我不解的是，当你谈到像为了研究而研究时，你知道直觉概念和软科学是不可避免的，即使在硬科学中，直觉概念和隐喻也被使用，对吧？但就像你受到了很多抨击，因为我会写一些东西，然后有人会给我发邮件说，你不应该有执照，因为你提到了潜意识，而潜意识不是基于证据的，这就像是什么意思？就像你们说潜意识不存在，我们只是自我，我们就是这样，现在你又回过头来说，好吧，卡尔·荣格还是错了。
And I'm never going to admit that. It's the same professors, too. I mean, these guys have been publishing since the 80s, but now it's trendy to talk about trauma. So they're like, well, there's primary, secondary and tertiary memory or there's implicit memory that is nonverbal and shows up as a symbol from the body brain as a trauma response and you're like oh you mean like an unconscious like what what this you're it's a semantic distinction but they're not ever gonna say i'm wrong or i was wrong yeah well and i i mean it's it's just so the emperor's new clothes because guess what we can't prove anything like there is no you know you can't prove anything everything in hard physics is a theory like it's not the same thing
而且我永远不会承认这一点。这也是同一批教授。我的意思是，这些人从80年代就开始发表文章了，但现在谈论创伤很时髦。所以他们会说，嗯，有初级、二级和三级记忆，或者有非语言的内隐记忆，它表现为来自身体大脑的创伤反应的象征，你会说，哦，你是说像潜意识一样？这只是语义上的区别，但他们永远不会说我错了或者我曾经错了。是的，我的意思是，这就像皇帝的新装，因为你猜怎么着，我们什么也证明不了，就像没有，你知道你什么也证明不了，硬物理学中的一切都是理论，这并不一样。
that will happen when that's just what it is yeah yeah like the same people who say well the unconscious doesn't have a space or whatever you i'll be like okay let's look at what you're writing and i'll look on the arlington article and they're like self-esteem is this new concept you're like self-esteem is still a metaphor like you can't just listen to a tube self-esteem is not evidence but like what right but it's a useful metaphor that helps people understand the phenomenology of how we think and helps them under break the self into parts to feel it and then get better so if it works what does it matter if I can't you know empirically validate every single part of the process, we can study the process and see if it works. Like exhibit A, antipsychotics, you know, we spend all this money trying to figure out why antipsychotics work. We know they work. You know, you're never going to
当这就是事实时，这种情况就会发生，是的，就像那些说潜意识没有空间或什么的同一群人，我会说，好吧，让我们看看你写的东西，我会看阿灵顿的文章，他们说自尊是一个新概念，你会说自尊仍然是一个隐喻，就像你不能只听一个管子，自尊不是证据，但像什么呢？对吧，但这是一个有用的隐喻，可以帮助人们理解我们思考的现象学，并帮助他们把自我分解成各个部分来感受它，然后变得更好，所以如果它有效，我是否能从经验上验证过程的每一个部分又有什么关系呢？我们可以研究这个过程，看看它是否有效。比如证据A，抗精神病药物，你知道，我们花这么多钱试图弄清楚为什么抗精神病药物有效。我们知道它们有效。你知道，你永远不会
tell somebody with schizophrenia who apparently schizophrenia go off your medication because we don't really know exactly why this works yet. Right. But we spend all this money about the dopamine theory of schizophrenia. 10 years later, it turns out we know less about why those work um now it's sensory gating is like the primary theory on on it but we spent all that money to figure out that we don't really know what our guess about why we thought it worked is wrong but we still prescribe antipsychotics because we know that as as a method they are effective not as a method they're effective even if we don't understand exactly what's happening so when you study ifs or eft or any of these things yes you can't validate every little vocabulary word that i have to use and most of it's going to be semantic anyway you know but
告诉精神分裂症患者，因为显然精神分裂症，停止服药，因为我们还不知道这到底为什么有效。对吧。但我们花了很多钱研究精神分裂症的多巴胺理论。10年后，结果发现我们对它们为什么有效知之甚少，嗯，现在感觉门控是关于它的主要理论，但我们花了那么多钱才发现，我们对为什么我们认为它有效而做出的猜测是错误的，但我们仍然开抗精神病药物，因为我们知道作为一种方法它们是有效的，即使我们不完全理解发生了什么，所以当你研究IFS或EFT或任何这些东西时，是的，你不能验证我必须使用的每一个词汇，而且大部分无论如何都是语义上的，你知道，但是
like you know that those things are effective because a patient with ptsd went into it and then 65 of them got better on the other side versus this other model but they don't want to do that kind of research yeah and even the people who do research don't it's like they don't get that i don't i don't understand um i know well i think they're so defensive because you have to be so defensive about yourself to even get to be successful in that area that it's like those people don't want to admit that the whole field is like basically a sham i'm sorry to say it's not even like soft like the thing is like you're gonna run into intuitive concepts and metaphors in soft science inevitably but even in very hard sciences they're still there i mean you sit in fifth grade and they tell you okay well here's the atom it's
就像你知道那些东西是有效的，因为一个患有创伤后应激障碍的病人参与了它，然后65%的人在另一边好转了，相比于其他模型，但他们不想做那种研究，是的，即使是做研究的人也不想做，就像他们不明白，我不明白，嗯，我知道，嗯，我认为他们太防御了，因为你必须对自己非常防御才能在那个领域取得成功，所以就像那些人不想承认整个领域基本上是一个骗局，我很抱歉说，这甚至不像软科学，问题是，你在软科学中不可避免地会遇到直觉概念和隐喻，但即使在非常硬的科学中，它们仍然存在，我的意思是，你坐在五年级，他们告诉你，好吧，这是原子，它是
a circle and it has to have the same amount of protons as electrons. And so the atom's happy when the hydrogen gets one electron and it's, then it isn't happy when it doesn't, whatever. That's all completely made up. Like there's subshells where a particle is popping in and out of existence and you're calculating a fraction of a possibility of where it might be. The atom's not happy. It's not happy. Like there's not a circle where there's two protons and then we're gonna dot two electrons that's what you teach people to start to understand the balance of forces in the natural world when they're in fifth grade like but you no one's going into you know the the fifth grade classroom and being like that's not evidence-based why don't you you know show them certain data like right right oh my gosh because you're you're building a bridge where they're starting to help them understand how these things interact and that's the ma and that's a metaphor
一个圆圈，它必须有相同数量的质子和电子。所以当氢得到一个电子时，原子就很高兴，然后当它没有时，它就不高兴，等等。这完全是编造的。就像有亚壳层，粒子在其中进进出出，你正在计算它可能在哪里的一小部分可能性。原子并不高兴。它不高兴。就像没有一个圆圈有两个质子，然后我们要点两个电子，这就是你教人们在五年级时开始理解自然界中力平衡的方法，就像但没有人会走进五年级的教室说，那不是基于证据的，为什么你不向他们展示某些数据，就像对，对，天哪，因为你正在建造一座桥梁，他们开始帮助他们理解这些东西是如何相互作用的，这就是隐喻
it's not true it's not true that adam's not happy there's not two electrons in a hoop around two protons and then they cancel out the electric force that isn't how atoms work yeah but we still use that to start to understand how these vastly complicated systems work in order to to use them and it's just sitting with that uncertainty causes a certain kind of clinician so much anxiety that they really want to run back to a model and say well i did this right but not wrong and i think that's where you start to get unethical because i never feel like i did it right or perfect i'm always running cases and being like what did what what do i not know what could i have done different what could i have seen coming you know yeah and i'm not you know the best clinician out there but i'm trying to be better all the time and you lose that ability when it's just well i'm going to read this book or do the ceo i'm going to do what they said
这不是真的，原子不高兴不是真的，两个质子周围的圆圈里没有两个电子，然后它们抵消了电力，原子不是那样工作的，是的，但我们仍然用它来开始理解这些极其复杂的系统是如何工作的，以便使用它们，而只是面对这种不确定性会导致某种临床医生产生如此多的焦虑，以至于他们真的想跑回一个模型说，好吧，我做对了，而不是做错了，我认为这就是你开始变得不道德的地方，因为我从来不觉得我做得对或完美，我总是运行案例，然后想，我不知道什么？我本可以做些什么不同的事情？我本可以预见到什么？你知道，是的，我不是最好的临床医生，但我一直在努力变得更好，当你只是说，好吧，我要读这本书或做继续教育，我要做他们说的
i think yeah yeah you get out of touch that's when you lose lose track of your intuition which is the thing that you can't study or manufacture you know that's when you know you just get so consumed and having to do things exactly like this person is saying but you can't you can't ever do that though because as you're saying i mean it kind of gets to the point of like, all language is metaphor, language is, and language is just how we, is how we structure all of our thought. But like language isn't evidence-based,
我想是的，是的，你失去了联系，那就是当你失去对直觉的追踪时，这是你无法研究或制造的东西，你知道，那就是当你变得如此被消耗，必须完全按照这个人说的那样去做，但你永远不能那样做，因为正如你所说，我的意思是，它有点到了像，所有语言都是隐喻，语言是，语言只是我们如何构建我们所有思想的方式。但语言不是基于证据的，
it's just our very like categorization of different concepts in our lives. And we've like created sound to signal to other people that we're thinking about this thing but you know yeah i mean yeah and i mean i think like there was some guy that was going off on twitter that was like no one you just you say that you you attack somebody's semantics or the way that they're using symbolic language when you don't like their point right but like so you know he was like you know you can never do this and like you should only just be terribly literally
它只是我们对生活中不同概念的分类。我们创造了声音来向其他人发出信号，表明我们正在思考这件事，但你知道，是的，我的意思是，是的，我认为就像推特上有一个人一直在说，没有人，你只是说你攻击某人的语义或他们使用符号语言的方式，当你不喜欢他们的观点时，对吧，但就像你知道，他说，你知道你永远不能这样做，你应该只极其字面地
metaphors or for weak losers that are are you know illogical and are ruled by emotion or whatever occam's razor blah blah blah and it's like occam didn't have a razor that is a metaphor the philosopher made like you did the thing like at the end of your post yeah yeah and like you said i mean in in what i would say before i mean electron electron like that's an it's it's like a way that we like kind of describe this type of energy but there's not like a little thing there like it's not i mean and how do you even define what a thing is because there's you know all energy is diffuse and there's really not a difference between you and everything that's around you. I'd be curious to see what you thought of this, because this is something that I've played around with for a little bit.
隐喻是给软弱的失败者的，他们是不合逻辑的，被情绪支配，或者奥卡姆剃刀什么的，等等，这就像奥卡姆没有剃刀，那是一个隐喻，哲学家制造的，就像你在帖子最后做的那样，是的，是的，就像你说的，我的意思是，在我之前说的，我的意思是电子电子，那是一种我们描述这种能量的方式，但那里并没有一个小东西，我的意思是，你甚至如何定义什么是东西？因为你知道所有的能量都是弥散的，你和你周围的一切之间真的没有区别。我很好奇你会怎么想，因为这是我玩了一段时间的东西。
Because I really like the history of the profession and reading by the fire with like the models that i really don't like that all came out in like the 90s when in health care and insurance is getting really corporatized and so everything had like solution focused or brief or time limited or like crisis centered in front of it you know like because they were trying to make it shorter but i think the models kind of the way they fit together they all seem to break down to me on like two axes like one is you know ego versus like unconscious subcortical brain so you know something like cbt is is very ego management strategies it's very ego based on that access whereas something like you know a union analysis or whatever is dealing you know only with the unconscious you know it's
因为我真的很喜欢这个职业的历史，在炉火旁阅读那些我真的不喜欢的模型，它们都是在90年代出来的，当时医疗保健和保险变得非常企业化，所以每件事前面都有以解决方案为中心、简短、有时限或以危机为中心，你知道，因为他们试图让它更短，但我认为这些模型它们组合在一起的方式，对我来说似乎都在两个轴上分解，一个是你知道自我与潜意识皮层下大脑，所以你知道像CBT是非常自我管理策略，它在那个轴上非常基于自我，而像荣格分析或什么的，你知道只处理潜意识，你知道它是
a depth psychology and then the other axis is that is it analytical where the provider has all the power and they're telling you oh you smoke cigarettes because your mom made you orally fixated or is it experiential are you being like i don't know what you're feeling or why you're doing it but i'm going to push you into that feeling and so something like gestalt therapy is going to be incredibly experiential or brain spotting is experiential you're pulling this person into a feeling i don't even know what they're feeling you know i'm just pulling them into that so that the brain can heal itself and i have faith that on the other side of facing this thing whereas analytical is well maybe your jaw's locking up because they wouldn't let you talk in school and so you learned you know yeah and but they to me
深度心理学，然后另一个轴是它是分析性的，提供者拥有所有的权力，他们告诉你，哦，你抽烟是因为你妈妈让你口欲固着，还是体验式的，你是说，我不知道你在感觉什么或为什么这样做，但我会把你推向那种感觉，所以像格式塔疗法将是极其体验式的，或者大脑点疗法是体验式的，你把这个人拉进一种感觉，我甚至不知道他们在感觉什么，你知道，我只是把他们拉进那个感觉，这样大脑就可以自我修复，我相信在面对这件事的另一面，而分析性的是，嗯，也许你的下巴锁住了，因为他们在学校不让你说话，所以你学会了，你知道，是的，但对我来说
that's that that's the access that you can put all the models on and see kind of how somebody's thinking that makes sense and what do you think about that or i don't know is that is that wrong no i mean i yeah i think i think so i mean i yeah they're all just kind of different ways of looking at the same thing that's always kind of what we what we get back to and like when you're saying like solution focused it's it's it's a way that they it it was like it's a reaction to insurance companies and so then we have research that backs it up and who's really funding that research and what schools is it from and where do they get their funding do they and where does big pharma giving their fund you know it's it's all linked.
这就是你可以把所有模型放在上面并看看某人是如何思考的轴，这很有道理，你对此怎么看？或者我不知道，那是错的吗？不，我的意思是，是的，我认为是这样，我的意思是，它们都只是看待同一件事的不同方式，这总是我们回到的话题，就像当你谈到以解决方案为中心时，它是对保险公司的一种反应，所以我们有支持它的研究，谁在真正资助这项研究？它来自哪些学校？他们从哪里获得资金？他们是否，大型制药公司在哪里提供资金？你知道，这一切都是相互关联的。
Well, I mean, the reason I think those axes are useful though, is that, I mean, they are all, all the models are trying to do the same thing and that you give people to feel better and change behavior. But there's different parts of,
嗯，我的意思是，我认为这些轴有用的原因，是，我的意思是，它们都是，所有的模型都在试图做同样的事情，你让人们感觉更好并改变行为。但有不同的部分，
I think phenomenology of consciousness that the inventors of the models are the people who gravitate to them. Don't want to sit with, you know? Yeah. Like even, you know, urban yalom's the
我认为意识的现象学，模型的发明者是那些被它们吸引的人。不想坐下来，你知道吗？是的。就像，你知道，欧文·亚隆的
existential therapy guy a ton of people come to therapy because of yalom but he still is so analytical like he's he really um like he's very kind of ego-based thinking about this i mean he has that quote in one of his books about how he went to see like the somatic medicine person and he didn't get any change at all and he did he doesn't think that that works but the most helpful thing the guy said was at the very end of it he was like well if the meditation like doesn't help you sleep um just remember that you can always get a gun and shoot yourself and then y'all was like oh wow and that really put things in perspective for me and whatever and it's like you're kind of telling in yourself you went into not an analytical ego language place you went into a
存在主义治疗师，很多人因为亚隆而来到治疗，但他仍然非常分析，就像他真的，嗯，就像他非常基于自我思考这个问题，我的意思是，他在他的一本书里有那句名言，关于他去看躯体医学的人，他根本没有得到任何改变，他认为那不起作用，但那个人说的最有帮助的话是在最后，他说，嗯，如果冥想不能帮助你入睡，嗯，记住你总是可以拿一把枪自杀，然后亚隆说，哦，哇，这真的让我对事情有了看法，等等，这就像你在告诉你自己，你进入的不是一个分析性的自我语言空间，你进入了一个
felt experience of like maybe i really don't matter too much on this. And, and Yalom's brilliant. You know, I'm not, I'm not like critiquing him, but he is very suspicious of anything that is not able to be understood in language.
感觉体验，就像也许我在这件事上真的不太重要。而且，亚隆很聪明。你知道，我不是在批评他，但他对任何不能用语言理解的东西都非常怀疑。
You know, he's, he, he's a, he's an existential guy. He likes, he likes us existential philosophy and is very kind of mind over mind over matter.
你知道，他是一个存在主义者。他喜欢存在主义哲学，非常倾向于唯心主义。
Right. Right. Yeah. Um, He likes us existential philosophy and is very kind of mind over mind over matter, right? Right. Yeah Yeah Trying to think Where you know, where do you fall in your practice after having done this for I mean you've been a therapist for what ten years Yeah Yeah, something around there I I having done this for, I mean, you've been a therapist for what, 10 years? Yeah. Uh, yeah, something around there. Um, I, yeah, I kind of, I, I started out really trying to be like extremely evidence-based, but I was also, I think evidence-based can mean stuff like
对。对。是的。嗯，他喜欢存在主义哲学，非常倾向于唯心主义，对吧？对。是的。是的。试图思考你在做了这个之后，你的实践处于什么位置？我的意思是，你做治疗师有多久了？十年？是的。是的，差不多吧。我，在做了这个之后，我的意思是，你做治疗师有多久了？10年？是的。嗯，是的，差不多吧。嗯，我，是的，我开始时真的试图变得极其基于证据，但我也认为基于证据可以指像
narrative therapy and, um, emotionally focused therapy. There are so many different practices that are evidence-based. Emotion focused therapy is pretty research therapy. There are so many different practices that are evidence based. Emotion focused therapy is pretty researchable. I mean, it's incredibly evidence based. That's all the people that are like, well, you have to do CBT because it's the gold standard for this. It's like, well, not in these areas. EFT is actually outranking it. So why aren't you doing that one? If you're really following the research as much as you're saying. I mean, Sue Johnson proved if you just take the partner's loved one or you put, put the patient's loved one in the room, their outcomes are like 50% better. The person doesn't
叙事疗法和情绪聚焦疗法。有这么多不同的实践是基于证据的。情绪聚焦疗法是相当研究性的疗法。有这么多不同的实践是基于证据的。情绪聚焦疗法是相当可研究的。我的意思是，它极其基于证据。这就是所有那些说，嗯，你必须做CBT，因为它是这个领域的黄金标准的人。就像，嗯，在这些领域不是。EFT实际上超过了它。所以如果你真的像你说的那样遵循研究，为什么你不做那个呢？我的意思是，苏·约翰逊证明了如果你只是把伴侣的爱人带进来，或者你把病人的爱人放在房间里，他们的结果会好50%。那个人不需要
have to say anything. Just somebody who they love going to therapy with and makes it better. But we don't do that as a profession. You know, we don't, most people are like, I'm an individual therapist. I'm not going to see your partner, you know? Yeah. I mean, and her work really, really really really um that was a big learning about attachment and the way that she taught it was a huge turning point for me and when i uh went to training with her in grad school it was just like everything fell into place when i saw sue johnson talk that she is so moving um and it just felt like i I was so into couples and it felt, oh my gosh, this is it. And this is it for every, I mean, talking about attachment and attachment injuries.
说什么。只是有人和他们一起去治疗，这让情况变得更好。但我们作为一个职业并不这样做。你知道，我们不，大多数人说，我是一个个人治疗师。我不会见你的伴侣，你知道吗？是的。我的意思是，她的工作真的，真的，真的，嗯，那是关于依恋的一个大教训，她教它的方式对我来说是一个巨大的转折点，当我在研究生院和她一起参加培训时，当我看到苏·约翰逊谈话时，一切都到位了，她太感人了，而且感觉就像我非常喜欢夫妻治疗，感觉，天哪，就是这个。这就是每一个，我的意思是，谈论依恋和依恋伤害。
And I think, and so that work just, I mean, that was like the backbone of most of how I practiced because that was the way I studied that was in couples work, but I brought it to families. And I love working with systems of relationships, i.e. couples and families. It's so powerful, but it is it's just very hard to actually get people to do it in the way that's effective. Like you can't like family therapy. You're supposed to have every single person in the family in the room, no matter what the issue is. And an empty chair if they are not there, if they have the flu that week or something. Right, right.
而且我认为，所以那项工作只是，我的意思是，那是我的大部分实践的骨干，因为那是我在夫妻工作中研究的方式，但我把它带到了家庭中。我喜欢与关系系统一起工作，即夫妻和家庭。它太强大了，但实际上很难让人以有效的方式去做。就像你不能像家庭治疗那样。你应该让家庭中的每个人都在房间里，无论问题是什么。如果他们不在，如果他们那周得了流感什么的，就放一把空椅子。对，对。
People react to their presence, even though they're not there. And when I worked in Colorado in community setting and in diversion, I would get juvenile diversion where it was like teenagers who would get in trouble for stuff. And we had an amazing program and they put all this funding into the diversion counseling. And so we got like as therapists, we got to basically do any type of therapy we wanted. And they got free indefinite therapy that no, none of the courts monitored or saw it. I got to do like really cool family work and it wasn't requiring, you know, it wasn't mandating that people have to be there. It was just the one kid. But then I ended up doing like couples work with their parents and things like that and just was seeing um like amazing results so quickly for these kids but then i come back here and to alabama and like nobody wants to take their whole family to there like and and it's sort of hard and it's hard to and i'm from here so i so i get that it's like that that is very outside of what anyone i don't
人们会对他们的存在做出反应，即使他们不在那里。当我在科罗拉多州的社区环境和分流项目中工作时，我会得到青少年分流，就像因为事情惹上麻烦的青少年。我们有一个很棒的项目，他们把所有的资金都投入到分流咨询中。所以我们作为治疗师，基本上可以做任何我们想做的治疗。他们得到了免费的无限期治疗，没有法院监控或看到它。我得做很酷的家庭工作，而且不需要，你知道，不需要强制人们必须在那里。只是那个孩子。但后来我最终和他们的父母做了夫妻工作之类的事情，只是看到了，嗯，就像对这些孩子如此迅速的惊人结果，但后来我回到这里，回到阿拉巴马州，就像没有人想把他们的整个家庭带去治疗，而且这有点难，而且很难，而且我是从这里来的，所以我明白，这就像那非常超出了任何人的范围，我不知道
you know it's just not something people think to do or it's just not in the canon of how people are here you can groups too i like we i mean there are a couple practices that were good and they tried to do these these iop groups and different things and it just people don't get it i mean we have this conception in alabama that group therapy is AA and that's it yeah and AA is not that yeah yeah it's not group therapy you know but it's like people just think if you're sitting in a circle you have to you have to be in recovery and I mean group therapy I don't know insurance doesn't pay for it here which is probably part of what started to kill it. Now they're wanting to pay for it again.
你知道，这只是人们没想到要做的事情，或者它只是不在人们在这里的准则中。你也可以分组，我喜欢我们，我的意思是，有几个实践很好，他们试图做这些IOP小组和不同的事情，但人们只是不明白，我的意思是，我们在阿拉巴马州有这样一个概念，即团体治疗是AA，就是这样，是的，AA不是那样，是的，是的，它不是团体治疗，你知道，但就像人们只是认为如果你坐在一个圆圈里，你必须处于康复状态，我的意思是团体治疗，我不知道，保险在这里不支付，这可能是开始扼杀它的原因。现在他们又想支付了。
Oh, they are? Yeah, they're trying to get people to do groups. Save money. Yeah. Well, there was just that whole period where it was like, we'll just tell people, we'll give people Band-Aids and I'll get them out faster. And then it ends up not treating trauma actually is a lot more expensive. So now it's kind of moving back the other way. Yeah. Yeah. Groups are a great example. I never even tried to practice. I mean, I, you know, with groups and as part of my private practice, just because it was like knowing how you actually make a good group, you're supposed to have this set number of people between these numbers,
哦，他们是吗？是的，他们试图让人做小组。省钱。是的。嗯，有一段时间就像，我们只是告诉人们，我们会给人们创可贴，我会让他们更快地离开。然后结果发现不治疗创伤实际上要昂贵得多。所以现在它有点向另一个方向移动。是的。是的。小组是一个很好的例子。我从来没有尝试过练习。我的意思是，我，你知道，把小组作为我私人诊所的一部分，只是因为就像知道你如何真正建立一个好的小组，你应该有这个固定数量的人，在这些数字之间，
you know, between eight to 12, eight to 10 people is ideal. And it's supposed to be the same people show up for a certain amount of time. But all the groups here are run where it's just like, anyone can show up to this about postpartum depression, it happens every day, blah, blah, blah, and you don't get the same group of people there. And the whole point of how group therapy works is that it's you know you're creating a family you're creating a family and everybody serves as like an archetype for what's going on in your subconscious and and same with like family work and couples work but groups don't work like that here in general like you're saying and um and it seems like it's like, even I found,
你知道，8到12人，8到10人是理想的。而且应该是同样的人在一段时间内出现。但这里所有的团体都是这样运行的，就像任何人都可以参加这个关于产后抑郁症的团体，它每天都在发生，等等，等等，你不会在那里得到同一群人。团体治疗如何工作的全部意义在于，你知道你正在创造一个家庭，你正在创造一个家庭，每个人都作为你潜意识里发生的事情的原型，家庭工作和夫妻工作也是如此，但团体在这里通常不是那样工作的，就像你说的，而且，看起来就像是，甚至我发现，
I just, I got very disillusioned with feeling like it's like the therapists don't even, most therapists that I talked to, or all therapists that I talked to don't know that even they don't even know, like they weren't even educated about like how a group should be run, for example. And people didn't get any, well, I guess we did have a group should be run for example and people didn't get any you know well i guess we did have a group therapy thing in my master's program and it's if you get any of it it's all based on y'all i mean this book is still the book yeah right right yeah but it's like people don't and to say and like couples work and family work i got i got pretty frustrated feeling like people were doing couple and family work who don't actually know what
我只是，我对感觉就像治疗师甚至，我交谈过的大多数治疗师，或者我交谈过的所有治疗师都不知道，甚至他们甚至不知道，就像他们甚至没有接受过关于小组应该如何运行的教育，例如。人们没有得到任何，嗯，我想我们确实有一个小组应该如何运行的例子，人们没有得到任何，你知道，嗯，我想我们在我的硕士课程中确实有一个团体治疗的东西，如果你得到任何它，它都是基于亚隆的，我的意思是这本书仍然是那本书，是的，对，对，是的，但就像人们没有，而且说，像夫妻工作和家庭工作，我感到非常沮丧，感觉人们在做夫妻和家庭工作，他们实际上不知道
they're doing with couples and families because I really do that in couple and family work you know you treat we kind of talked about this a little bit but you treat the relationship instead of the individuals and so and it's extreme especially with families it's so powerful to work like that but it's just i don't know it's it's it's tough to get people to keep showing up and yeah and men men don't want to go to therapy you know it's just this whole um well and i think therapy in general has just gotten a lot harder it's gotten more expensive you know a lot of those trauma modalities like um i mean i'm coming off the second wave of ett and it's just like i'm i'm out i don't know how long it'll take to make that money back
他们在对夫妻和家庭做什么，因为我真的在夫妻和家庭工作中这样做，你知道，我们谈论了一点，但你治疗的是关系而不是个人，所以，而且它非常，特别是在家庭中，这样工作太强大了，但只是我不知道，让人保持出现真的很难，是的，而且男人，男人不想去治疗，你知道，这只是整个，嗯，而且我认为治疗总体上变得难多了，变得更贵了，你知道，很多那些创伤模式，比如，嗯，我的意思是，我刚结束ETT的第二波，就像我退出了，我不知道需要多长时间才能把那些钱赚回来
and i had a wait list before i did the training i did it because i wanted to be a better therapist but it's not like it was making me more marketable i already was full right um so it's like you you carry these thousands of dollars of these new trauma modalities you know the brains four phases of brain spotting or whatever um that works and it's like a second master's degree so i mean therapy overall has gotten a lot more expensive insurance is less blue cross still does a pretty good job but most insurance is more reticent to pay for different things people are just working two and three jobs um because the economy
而且我在做培训之前有一个等待名单，我做它是为了成为一个更好的治疗师，但并不是说它让我更有市场，我已经满了，对，嗯，所以就像你背负着这些数千美元的这些新创伤模式，你知道，大脑点疗法的四个阶段什么的，这有效，而且就像第二个硕士学位，所以我的意思是，治疗总体上变得贵多了，保险更少了，蓝十字仍然做得很好，但大多数保险更不愿意支付不同的东西，人们只是做两三份工作，因为经济
is different when do i go to therapy i mean i i have that issue where i i want to see my therapist really more than i'm able to yeah yeah um and so when you have an entire family schedule i mean how do you it's like we can't even eat dinner together when are we going to go to therapy yeah yeah i know um yeah because they have to be at a certain time you know it has to be like after work and oh what i was thinking i mean this is you're talking about something that's it's just like i've sort of gotten to where i feel like it like the whole does it feel like the whole field is sort of this pyramid scheme like it sort of turned into this pyramid scheme where it's like okay in order to be successful you need to keep adding on these trainings and these trainings and
不同，我什么时候去治疗？我的意思是，我有那个问题，我真的想见我的治疗师，比我能做到的更多，是的，是的，所以当你有一个完整的家庭时间表时，我的意思是，你怎么能？就像我们甚至不能一起吃晚饭，我们什么时候去治疗？是的，是的，我知道，嗯，是的，因为他们必须在特定的时间，你知道，它必须像下班后，哦，我在想什么，我的意思是，你谈论的是某件事，它就像我已经到了那种感觉，就像整个领域感觉像是一个金字塔计划吗？它有点变成了这个金字塔计划，就像，好吧，为了成功，你需要不断增加这些培训和这些培训，以及
paint and paying these you know pay the gotmans this much money to use this practice which whereas like the boards are going to tell us like it's not evidence-based if you're not doing this therapy that you're going to have to pay this much money to even say you're doing it's's just, yeah, that is something that I, I am really turned off by some of those models is you can read the book and understand the system and see what he's doing. But I mean, some of those trainings, they're like, okay, you can pay $2,000 and you can do level one through three, but you can't even say that you do this model without getting sued by me until you've gotten this whatever. And she's like man no like you know
支付，支付这些，你知道，付给戈特曼夫妇这么多钱来使用这种实践，而董事会会告诉我们，如果你不做这种治疗，你将不得不支付这么多钱才能说你在做，这根本不是基于证据的，是的，那是我真的很反感的一些模型，你可以读这本书并理解这个系统，看看他在做什么。但是我的意思是，其中一些培训，他们就像，好吧，你可以支付2000美元，你可以做第一到第三级，但在你获得这个什么什么之前，你甚至不能说你做这个模型，否则会被我起诉。她说，伙计，不，就像你知道
i don't i don't know and like mental health practitioners do not have money for you know it's like yeah we already don't you know you know we don't make any money like which is fine but like but it's it just feels very victimizing of yeah of people who already i mean not to mention the clients like well just the microtransactions of on everything that modernity is kind of moving the economy towards where it's like you can't own the movie you can't own the whatever you just have to pay 20 to every screaming streaming service ever all the time and right you know what is even i mean it's not just therapy i mean a lot of these realities just are across industry but um yeah and it's like well what did we pay for to have our degree and our license because it's like that doesn't
我不知道，而且像心理健康从业者没有钱，你知道，这就像，是的，我们已经没有，你知道，你知道我们不赚钱，这很好，但它只是感觉非常受害，那些已经，我的意思是，更不用说客户了，就像，只是现代性正在推动经济发展的微交易，就像你不能拥有电影，你不能拥有什么，你只是必须一直支付20美元给每一个流媒体服务，对，你知道那是什么，我的意思是，这不仅仅是治疗，我的意思是，很多这些现实只是跨行业的，但嗯，是的，就像我们付钱是为了什么，为了获得我们的学位和执照，因为那并不
it's well and at least for the masters i went to i mean you really didn't learn how to do therapy in school i mean i was trying to take classes and read books and which is expensive you know academic books to know how to do therapy for four years so that I could do it because I didn't feel like, you know, the couple of classes on CBT and DBT that I got in school were going to prepare me to do it. Yeah. Well, I, I, okay. I did feel like my program was really, really great for actually learning therapy um and i don't know if that was a function of it be of it being a cpce counselor counseling psychology and counselor education program which i didn't even really know the distinction before i went into my program and then figured out that it was
它是，嗯，至少对于我去的硕士学位，我的意思是，你在学校真的没有学到如何做治疗，我的意思是，我试图上课和读书，这很贵，你知道，学术书籍，为了知道如何做治疗四年，这样我就可以做它，因为我不觉得，你知道，我在学校得到的关于CBT和DBT的几门课会准备好让我做它。是的。嗯，我，我，好吧。我确实觉得我的项目在实际学习治疗方面真的，真的很好，嗯，我不知道这是否是它作为一个CPCE咨询心理学和咨询教育项目的功能，我在进入我的项目之前甚至不知道区别，然后发现它是
like oh i really like that it's like preparing you to either be a therapist or teach therapists how to do it. And I, you know, if you like the history of psychology and stuff, it's like so much fun to study how therapy, the way that you could like help other therapists. It's so fascinating. And it was, yeah, I felt very, very prepared. And we worked in the, we were counselors in the, um, in the university counseling center where we had like glass and, and people and our peers like watched us through the glass and on. Yeah. I mean, the LBC programs, you definitely get way, way more therapy stuff, you know, only cause it's like, it's what they do, you know, where social work's huge. I mean, y'all could manage a nonprofit. I could work with with geriatrics i could be on a psych ward so
就像，哦，我真的很喜欢它，它就像准备让你要么成为治疗师，要么教治疗师如何做。而且我，你知道，如果你喜欢心理学的历史之类的，研究治疗是多么有趣，你可以像帮助其他治疗师一样，这太迷人了。而且它是，是的，我感到非常，非常有准备。而且我们在大学咨询中心工作，我们有玻璃，人们和我们的同龄人通过玻璃看着我们，而且在。是的。我的意思是，LPC项目，你肯定会得到更多，更多治疗的东西，你知道，只是因为就像，这是他们做的，你知道，社会工作很大。我的意思是，你们可以管理一个非营利组织。我可以和老年病学一起工作，我可以在精神病院，所以
there's yeah there's all you know it's the difference in whatever um but i think that you know the upside is you come out of school not gonna do therapy as an lpc which is nice and one of the downsides is you can't really do anything else so there's some people who sort of get tired of doing therapy or don't really like people but then they are an lpc so they can't go do this short job so they're kind of that's that's one that you want to be really sure that you want to do therapy forever before you agree because you know i can reinvent myself and hop around you know as a social worker into different different uh a ton of different areas so true you know really not a ton of social workers are
有，是的，有，你知道，这是任何东西的区别，嗯，但我认为，你知道，好处是你从学校出来，作为LPC不做治疗，这很好，而且缺点之一是你真的不能做任何其他事情，所以有些人有点厌倦做治疗，或者不太喜欢人，但他们是LPC，所以他们不能去做这个短期的工作，所以他们有点，那是，那是你想要非常确定你想要永远做治疗，在你同意之前，因为你知道，我可以重塑自己，四处跳跃，你知道，作为一名社会工作者，进入不同的，不同的，嗯，一吨不同的领域，太真实了，你知道，真的没有一吨社会工作者是
working in therapy exclusively yeah it is mostly social workers at taffy though christy marie are all i feel like in alabama i just feel and in colorado there were like um it's it's i mean it's so different state to state you know that's another part of kind of what we're talking about is it's which licenses are the good ones to have or is different state to state. Like, I feel like my LMFT is not that big of a, it's not that super valuable in Alabama. Insurance doesn't pay for it. Like the LMFTs that want to bill for insurance, what you have to do is say, well, this is the identified patient and that's the collateral patient who's there to come to help this patient's goals. But if you divorce or something, only the patient has the right to the medical record and then you bill it as individual therapy.
专门从事治疗，是的，虽然克里斯蒂·玛丽都是，我觉得在阿拉巴马州，我只是觉得，在科罗拉多州，有，嗯，它是，我的意思是，州与州之间太不同了，你知道，那是我们正在谈论的另一种，是哪些执照是好的，或者州与州之间是不同的。就像，我觉得我的LMFT在阿拉巴马州不是那么大，它不是那么有价值。保险不支付它。就像想要为保险计费的LMFT，你必须做的是说，好吧，这是确定的病人，那是为了来帮助这个病人的目标的附属病人。但如果你离婚什么的，只有病人有权获得医疗记录，然后你把它作为个人治疗计费。
You know, I don't do marriage counseling, but that's that's what most of the marriage counselors do if it's covered by insurance. Right. Which I don't know. You know, I that's going to make it a lot harder for LMFTs to have a big marriage and family therapy practice. But then if you're in somewhere like Colorado, LMFTs are paid more than everybody else. I was going to say California. California.
你知道，我不做婚姻咨询，但如果保险覆盖的话，大多数婚姻咨询师都是这样做的。对。我不知道。你知道，我，这会让LMFT拥有大型婚姻和家庭治疗实践变得更加困难。但如果你在像科罗拉多州这样的地方，LMFT的薪水比其他任何人都高。我正要说加利福尼亚州。加利福尼亚州。
But I do feel like workers are way more, in Alabama, way more. I don't know. It's bigger, but I don't know. I feel like they're more respected in Alabama. Yeah, you do definitely want to know the state you're moving to and the state you're in when you're going to school. Because school is so expensive now. You just don't want to get the wrong degree. Right.
但我确实觉得社会工作者在阿拉巴马州要多得多。我不知道。它更大，但我不知道。我觉得他们在阿拉巴马州更受尊重。是的，你肯定想知道你要搬到的州和你上学时所在的州。因为学校现在太贵了。你只是不想拿到错误的学位。对。
I was wondering, could you say anything about brain spotting? When Alice starts with us, she'll have the brain spotting training like everybody else that does the individual adult therapy at Taproot. So you had tried a little bit of it and then decided to get the training. Do you want to say anything about the experience or you want to kind of wait until you're out of training? I don't know. I was just wondering if you could give people who are listening who may want to come see you that are local or anything, some information about training. Yeah. I mean, okay, so, yeah, I have not done the training yet. So I'm not – my blurb is not going to be –
我想知道，你能说一下大脑点疗法吗？当爱丽丝和我们开始时，她会像在Taproot做个人成人治疗的每个人一样接受大脑点疗法培训。所以你尝试了一点，然后决定接受培训。你想说一下这次经历，还是你想等到培训结束后再说？我不知道。我只是想知道你是否可以给那些正在听、可能想来看你、是本地人或什么的听众提供一些关于培训的信息。是的。我的意思是，好吧，所以，是的，我还没有做培训。所以我不是——我的简介不会是——
but I am excited about – so, okay, I love, my practice kind of led me into more trauma-based, are you still there? Mm-hmm. Okay, trauma-based therapy. Like, I just, I ended up having a lot of women who were coming to me with history of sexual abuse, whether it's people presenting for eating disorders, people presenting for depression, people presenting for all these different things. And then it's like, actually, okay, everyone has sexual trauma apparently. So it's, I, I think it's like, there's so much trauma that people just don't even know how to begin to get into like get to acknowledge that it's there or really even um like identify it as trauma like yeah like my uh
但我很兴奋——所以，好吧，我喜欢，我的实践引导我进入更多基于创伤的，你还在那里吗？嗯嗯。好的，基于创伤的治疗。就像，我最终有很多女性来找我，有性虐待史，无论是表现为饮食失调的人，表现为抑郁症的人，表现为所有这些不同事情的人。然后就像，实际上，好吧，每个人显然都有性创伤。所以它，我，我认为它就像，有太多的创伤，人们甚至不知道如何开始进入，就像开始承认它在那里，或者真的甚至，嗯，就像把它识别为创伤，就像，是的，就像我的，嗯
like my mom i was like my mom was gonna watch this or not like my mom had an abuser when she was little and when i finally found out about it it's like she's just mom was going to watch this or not. Like my mom had an abuser when she was little. And when I finally found out about it, it's like, she's just sort of like, she didn't identify it as abuse. Like she didn't say it like that. It's like, it's like, this was a creepy tennis, tennis teacher who blah, blah, blah, like touched her. And I don't know, but she, it's like something she thinks sort of is funny. And it's like, no, you were like, and like, that like that's not right but people kind of and so it would never that's what's interesting those
就像我妈妈，我当时想我妈妈会不会看这个，或者不，就像我妈妈小时候有一个施虐者，当我最终发现它时，就像她只是妈妈会不会看这个，或者不。就像我妈妈小时候有一个施虐者。当我最终发现它时，就像，她只是有点像，她没有把它识别为虐待。就像她没有那样说。它就像，它就像，这是一个令人毛骨悚然的网球，网球教练，谁等等，等等，就像摸了她。我不知道，但她，它就像她认为有点好笑的事情。而且就像，不，你当时就像，而且就像，那是不对的，但人们有点，所以它永远不会，这就是有趣的，那些
those defensive parts when you're doing brain spotting they flare up uh-huh and one of the things that the most one of the reactions that the most they because it's the patient feels embarrassed and i'm always like no this is you know qualified and you help make room for it one of the most common reactions with the most traumatized people is you know they their body feels all sweaty and hot and like they don't want to re-experience the thing and then they start laughing and then they can't stop laughing but going back into that place that's this pretty strong defensive reaction is my mother for sure the brain spotting will pull you through it i'm like no just laugh as much as you need to we're still going to go through the version's like i'm sorry i'm taking it seriously i'm not laughing
在进行脑点定位（Brainspotting）时，那些防御性的部分会突然爆发。最常见的反应之一是患者会感到尴尬，而我总是说：“不，这是正常的，你是合格的，我们要为它留出空间。”对于受创伤最深的人来说，最常见的反应之一是身体感到出汗、发热，他们不想重温那件事，然后开始大笑，接着就停不下来。但回到那个地方，这是一种相当强烈的防御反应，我母亲肯定会说脑点定位会带你走出来。我说：“不，你想笑就笑吧，我们还是要继续。”对方会说：“抱歉，我是在认真对待，我不是在嘲笑你。”
at you i'm like i understand i've done it myself like let's go through yeah yeah i mean it's and i i really have come around to being this is part of what i was disillusioned with was just so many of our approach or all of the approaches besides maybe EMDR are so based in like you need to be able to put into words what happened to you and you need to like with EMDR though you're starting the analysis of it well well even with EMDR you're still like what is the happy belief let's replace what's the bad belief let's replace it you know as soon as they start to feel anything you're talking you know whereas with brain spotting you talk as long as you need to to get them to go down there but once they're there be quiet and get out of the way let them go yeah you know the deep brain knows what it's more but
我说：“我明白，我自己也经历过，我们继续吧。”是的，我真的转变了观念，这就是我曾经感到幻灭的一部分原因。我们太多的方法，或者说除了EMDR（眼动脱敏再加工）之外的所有方法，都太基于“你需要能够用语言表达发生在你身上的事情”，而且你需要……虽然EMDR也是这样，你开始分析它。好吧，即使在EMDR中，你仍然会想：“什么是快乐的信念？让我们替换它。什么是糟糕的信念？让我们替换它。”你知道，一旦他们开始有任何感觉，你就在说话。而在脑点定位中，你可以谈论你需要的时间来引导他们深入，但一旦他们到了那里，就保持安静，别挡路，让他们去吧。是的，深层大脑知道它需要什么。
it was like EMDR I always felt like because I mean it works EMDR works and it was the best tool that I had when I was first coming out of school but for very very traumatized people or dissociation it's like you're fighting past those defenses for so long with these eye movements i mean i was doing two-hour sessions sometimes um and it's effective but it just brain spotting was more effective for more people more of the time more profoundly and i'm always looking for what is the kind of biggest biggest net yeah um i dogs are barking yeah i it's i i think it's just i i think being through uh having a, so I had a lot of trauma, trauma growing up. That's like complex trauma where it's like, I can't, it's very hard to pinpoint individual times.
就像EMDR，我一直觉得，因为它确实有效，EMDR是有效的，也是我刚毕业时拥有的最好工具。但对于受创伤极深的人或解离症患者来说，就像你一直在用这些眼动动作与那些防御机制抗争。我的意思是，我有时会进行两小时的疗程，虽然有效，但脑点定位对更多的人在更多时候更有效，也更深刻。我一直在寻找最大的“网”。是的，狗在叫。我想，经历过……我成长过程中有很多创伤。那是复杂的创伤，很难指出具体的时间点。
And so with EMDR, you know, you're supposed to come up with these, like a list of all your trauma. And like, as a person who has had trauma, it's just like, I, it's like therapists. Do you even understand what it is to have had like trauma your whole childhood? Because I'm not going to be able to come up with a list of like five things.
所以用EMDR，你需要列出你所有的创伤清单。作为一个经历过创伤的人，这就像……治疗师们，你们甚至理解在整个童年时期都经历创伤是什么感觉吗？因为我根本无法列出五件事。
Five. And you're stopped. I never felt like, you know, what do you mean? Tell me the event, you know? Yeah.
五件。然后你就卡住了。我从来没觉得……你是什么意思？告诉我那个事件，你知道吗？是的。
Yeah. Yeah. I don't have an event like, okay, I can identify. Okay. My sister had a big boating accident. Okay, that's, that's an event. But like, all the rest of the stuff was some kind of coping mechanism dissociation or whatever but because you can't feel it it's stored you know and then you have to go back and process it later but some of that is acute that there's a boating accident or car wreck or somebody hits me when i'm a kid or something but a ton of it may be so nebulous that it's hard to even find or identify like you know i had like a lot of patients that i've had
是的。我没有一个我可以明确指出的事件。好吧，我姐姐发生过一次严重的划船事故，那是件大事。但剩下的所有事情都是某种应对机制、解离或其他什么。但因为你感觉不到它，它被储存起来了，你以后必须回去处理它。有些是急性的，比如划船事故、车祸，或者我小时候被人打之类的，但其中很大一部分可能非常模糊，以至于很难找到或识别。你知道，我有很多病人……
they've had a patient the parents that were real moralistic or religious. And the, the parent never said anything that even if you had a transcript would constitute emotional abuse, they were just always being like, you don't understand how the world is. Everyone out there is going to try and get you and you, everyone in the world. And there's all these evil forces and, you know, look everywhere all the time and, and, and the child is panicking and afraid of everything but they don't even know what they're afraid you know what i mean like and that their whole experience with life is that it's scary and bad and gonna hurt them and that is the trauma you know and it never it's not one thing it's this nebulous whatever how do you target something like that you know yeah um and i guess emdr cbct would say turn it into a belief um but i mean something like that is just
他们有那种非常道德主义或宗教色彩的父母。父母从来没说过任何话，即使你有文字记录也构不成情感虐待，他们只是总是说：“你不了解这个世界是什么样的。外面的每个人都想害你，世界上的每个人都是。有各种邪恶的力量，你要时刻提防。”孩子会感到恐慌，害怕一切，但他们甚至不知道自己在怕什么。你知道我的意思吗？他们对生活的全部体验就是它很可怕、很糟糕，会伤害他们，这就是创伤。它不是一件事，它是这种模糊的东西。你怎么去针对这样的东西呢？是的，我想EMDR或CBCT会说把它变成一个信念，但像这样的事情……
so complex and huge it's somebody never felt safe anywhere in their life and that's one of the things with complex trauma patients a ton the first session is i'll ask them do they kind of go through their history and i'm like is there anywhere in your life ever that you felt safe and they'll think and they're like no that is so sad and it's like the first time that they've realized like oh I went from this childhood to this relationship to this relationship to this marriage to now where I'm out and trying and they never had any place where they felt okay right right and that's something so nebulous that it, I think it's very, when I was in the middle of some punctuated acute trauma that where I was going to therapy for this, like a few years ago, it was, it's so, it's so minimizing to be asked to like put into words stuff that you've never been able and it makes you feel like your trauma is not legitimate if you're not able to describe it to somebody but i really think that there's also like we shouldn't have to describe it because i really believe that putting language to things where we are our brains haven't put stored them in a language place like i think that that's like a lower level of consciousness and our traumas are stored in this place where it's like your brain is trying to radiate them out of you and to put them into words.
太复杂、太庞大了。有人一生中从未感到安全，这是复杂创伤患者的一个特点。很多时候，第一次疗程我会问他们，回顾他们的历史，我会问：“你生命中有没有哪个时刻感到安全？”他们会思考，然后说：“没有。”这太令人难过了。这就像他们第一次意识到：“哦，我从这个童年到这段关系，再到那段关系，再到这段婚姻，到现在我走出来了，试图努力，但我从来没有一个感到安全的地方。”这太模糊了，我认为，当我处于某种突发的急性创伤中，几年前我为此接受治疗时，被要求用语言表达那些你从未能表达的东西，这太贬低人了。如果你不能向别人描述它，这会让你觉得你的创伤是不合法的。但我真的认为我们不应该去描述它，因为我坚信，当我们的大脑还没有将事物存储在语言区域时，强行赋予语言……我认为那是较低层次的意识，而我们的创伤存储在这样一个地方：你的大脑正试图将其辐射出来，而将其转化为语言……
Like artificial words is like a way of crystallizing the trauma. And I think locking it in more than it needs to be because the words are never going to even. I mean, and the words are not going to represent what I mean, like with EMDR, where we have this. Like I love the list of like fears and like beliefs, faulty beliefs about yourself that you get when you do the training, like the list of, okay, is my belief I am worthless? I can't trust myself. I am going to be abandoned. Like it's a very lovely little list to have, but it's still like people go down the list and then they're trying to narrow down which one so there's just like this artificiality about it no
就像人工语言一样，这是一种将创伤结晶化的方式。我认为这比它需要的更锁定了它，因为语言永远无法代表……我的意思是，语言无法代表我的意思。就像EMDR，我们有这个……我喜欢你在培训时得到的关于恐惧和信念的清单，关于你自己的错误信念，比如：“我的信念是我毫无价值吗？我不能相信自己。我会被抛弃。”这是一个非常可爱的清单，但它仍然让人觉得人们在清单上走来走去，试图缩小范围，所以这其中有一种人为性。
matter how you cut it somebody else's words and you can't like beliefs don't have are not necessarily stored as words it's stored as instinct and intuition you know when it's that trauma or somebody could have been unconscious during a trauma their body remembers something that intellectually i don't have access to they could have been drugged you know children make memories at different ages in ways that are pretty kind of semantic um you know like you don't start to have like narrative dreams until you're three or four you know two-year-old will just dream like a color or an object and then they'll say it like um and and so like a ton of times it's never gonna be and even if it even if you do have that
无论你怎么看，那都是别人的话，你不能……信念不一定是以文字形式存储的，它是作为本能和直觉存储的。你知道，当那是创伤时，或者某人在创伤期间可能处于无意识状态，他们的身体记得一些我在理智上无法获取的东西。他们可能被下药了。你知道，儿童在不同年龄以相当语义化的方式制造记忆。你知道，直到三四岁你才会有叙事性的梦。两岁的孩子只会梦见颜色或物体，然后他们会说出来。所以很多时候，它永远不会……即使你确实……
sort intellectually and you do come across a repressed memory or something which is not terribly common um you know but possible it's never gonna the the point is never well is colonel mustard in the green room with the rope this This is what happened. You go through the emotion first. You go through the body first and you regulate and you get all this out. And if the memory needs to come back, it will. It doesn't always need to come back. And that's never the point. That's where you get therapists that are kind of implanting memories
在理智上整理好了，你确实遇到了一个被压抑的记忆或其他什么，这并不常见，但有可能。重点从来不是“科隆·马斯塔德上校是不是在绿色的房间里拿着绳子？这就是发生的事情。”你首先要经历情绪。你首先要经历身体，然后你调节，你把这一切释放出来。如果记忆需要回来，它会回来的。它并不总是需要回来。那从来不是重点。这就是为什么有些治疗师会植入记忆……
and suggesting things because you're trying to do all this analytical stuff. I mean, there's so many people who had this just profound change and you know we had a pretty good idea probably what happened to them as a kid in some environment but it the point was to get better it wasn't to ever completely remember that experience and in some cases they couldn't ever completely remember that experience because they were semi-conscious or um you know they they were using drugs or something and it's like the memory wasn't written into the brain perfectly like a video we think of ptsd like we still think of ptsd as a culture like it's shot in movies you know that's the firework goes off at the cookout and then somebody's like bob bob you okay and and the
并暗示一些事情，因为你试图做所有这些分析性的工作。我的意思是，有很多人经历了这种深刻的改变，我们大概知道他们小时候在某种环境中发生了什么，但重点是好起来，而不是永远完全记住那个经历。在某些情况下，他们根本无法完全记住那个经历，因为他们处于半意识状态，或者他们使用了药物之类的。记忆并没有像视频一样完美地写入大脑。我们作为一个文化仍然认为PTSD就像电影里拍的那样，你知道，野餐时烟花爆炸了，然后有人说：“鲍勃，鲍勃，你还好吗？”然后……
footage of vietnam plays on the tape. It's not that. It's that my body is starting to feel like I'm angry. I need to fight. And then you say something that's a little bit off. And then I have an out-of-size reaction to that. And my emotions are kind of running the show. That's it. More so than the little videotape of the bad experience that just plays and plays.
越南的镜头在磁带上播放。不是那样的。而是我的身体开始觉得我很生气。我需要战斗。然后你说了一些有点不对劲的话。然后我对那个反应过度了。我的情绪在主导一切。就是这样。这比那个不断播放的糟糕经历的小录像带更重要。
The re-experiencing is real. But it's very, you know, maybe 10 of it is is visual or you know prefrontal cortex memory right because your prefrontal cortex shuts down when you're in fight or flight which is why it's like we don't naturally it's a lack of sync i mean that's my body's feeling something that i know isn't true up here and And then I keep feeling that thing. And, you know, a lot of the newer research on why brain spawning or psilocybin or a lot of the brain based medicine works is that it's rethinking the parasympathetic and the sympathetic nervous system. So they're on the same page. Yeah.
重温是真实的。但它非常……你知道，也许10%是视觉的，或者前额叶皮层的记忆，对吧？因为当你处于战斗或逃跑状态时，你的前额叶皮层会关闭，这就是为什么我们不会自然地……这是一种不同步。我的意思是，我的身体感觉到了我知道在这里（理智上）是不真实的东西。然后我继续感觉到那个东西。你知道，关于为什么脑点定位、裸盖菇素或许多基于大脑的药物有效，很多新的研究认为，这是在重新思考副交感神经和交感神经系统。所以它们在同一页面上。是的。
Yeah. But we don't. Yeah. It's need to do that from a higher level rather than from our intellectual level, I really think. I mean, and some of my most profound work was with clients who had, you know, sexual abuse or neglect or things like that, where we never actually like had a session where somebody is like intimately describing being touched or, you know, things like that. Like it's like you kind of like with some people, it was just like, you know, like talk around it like you flow with the person and let's kind of brush up against it but like
是的。但我们不需要从更高层面而不是从我们的理智层面来做这件事，我真的这么认为。我的意思是，我最深刻的一些工作是与那些有性虐待或忽视等经历的客户一起完成的，我们从来没有真正进行过那种有人亲密地描述被触摸或类似事情的疗程。就像你和某些人一样，只是谈论它，你与那个人一起流动，让我们稍微触碰一下它，但……
you would say being the tail of the comet you're going to hear that at brain spotting training a whole lot that the patient's experience is going and that you can kind of observe it but you don't want to get in the way or direct it you're just following it and letting it let it go with the energy yeah yeah i think and i i would see clients who um i was okay so i was seeing following it and letting it go with the energy. Yeah. Yeah. I think, and I, I would see clients who I was, okay. So I was seeing a lot of people who are presenting more with like sexual abuse and trauma and was really loving that work dissociative disorders.
你会说成为彗星的尾巴，你在脑点定位培训中会经常听到这个词，即患者的体验正在进行，你可以观察它，但你不想挡路或引导它，你只是跟随它，让它随能量而去。是的，我想……我会看到客户，我当时……我在跟随它，让它随能量而去。是的。我想，我会看到客户，我当时……我在看很多表现出性虐待和创伤的人，真的很喜欢那项工作，解离性障碍。
But the people who I was seeing with dissociative identity disorder had been to therapists who it felt like to me or it sounded like to me had basically like like even more crystallized the parts that were there like instead of writing the parts that it's like the therapist it's like it's like this self-indulgent therapy thing where it's like they're trying to get the overall part to come out. I know exactly the models of psychotherapy that you're talking about. Yeah, and it's where it's like I'm just going to take a borderline person and regress them down to a two-year-old and then reenact this fight about maternal whatever with them. Yeah, I know what you mean.
但我看到的那些患有解离性身份障碍的人，他们去看过的治疗师，对我来说，或者听起来，基本上就像……甚至更结晶化了那些存在的部分，而不是整合这些部分。这就像治疗师……这是一种自我放纵的治疗，他们试图让整体部分显现出来。我完全知道你在说哪种心理治疗模型。是的，就是那种我要把一个边缘型人格的人退行到两岁，然后和他们重演关于母性什么的争斗。是的，我知道你的意思。
I've seen those. But there's not an integrative part. It's this re-experiencing of the individual part. The parts aren't naturally coming out there like as, but you know, parts come out to cope with something in the moment. And so if you're unnaturally dragging a part out, you're connecting,
我见过那些。但没有一个整合的部分。这是对个体部分的重温。这些部分并不是自然地显现出来的，你知道，部分是为了应对当下的某种事情而显现的。所以如果你不自然地拖出一个部分，你是在连接……
it's, I don't know, you know, you're connecting it to different parts of the experience that that part doesn't necessarily need to be involved in. Yeah. Yeah, it can be very re-traumatizing. My experience with EMDR was exactly what you were describing.
我不知道，你是在把它连接到那个部分不一定需要参与的体验的不同部分。是的，这可能会造成再次创伤。我对EMDR的体验和你描述的完全一样。
It was like I saw it do magic for 30% of people and do nothing for 70% and was like, what is the part for people who this works for? And what is it really doing? And I love the little belief list at first, and then slowly started to find that limiting. And then I, and then my practice has evolved a lot, you know, but I was saying like, okay, I'm going to do a somatic trauma map. So we're not even going to worry about talking about the belief and the good thing and replacing whatever. We're just going to do like this whole thing of like emotionally, what this would feel like where is it physically in your body how does your posture want to move you know all in the person trying to get that subcortical activity and then i would
就像我看到它对30%的人产生了魔力，对70%的人毫无作用，我就想，对那些有效的人来说，关键部分是什么？它到底在做什么？我起初喜欢那个小小的信念清单，然后慢慢开始发现它有限制性。然后我的实践演变了很多，但我当时说：“好吧，我要做一个躯体创伤图。”所以我们甚至不去担心谈论信念和好的东西以及替换什么。我们只是要做整个事情，比如在情感上，这在身体上感觉如何？它在你的身体里哪里？你的姿势想怎么动？所有这些都是为了让那个人尝试获得那种皮层下的活动。然后我会……
start doing the eye movements and that's when i would notice that when the eye movement would go past a certain spot the pupil would wibble and so i was like well what if i stop here and then people started going into crashing into processing. And I didn't know what I was doing. And then multiple people, EMDR was just so protocol-driven. I kept paying for more trainings. And they were like, no, don't do that. Just do the 15.
开始做眼动，那时我会注意到，当眼动经过某个点时，瞳孔会颤动。所以我当时想，如果我在这里停下来会怎样？然后人们开始进入处理状态。我不知道我在做什么。然后很多人，EMDR太依赖协议了。我不断支付更多的培训费用。他们说：“不，不要那样做。只做那15个。”
And I was like, but they're asking me to do it. The patient's been in EMDR forever. I haven't been a therapist for two months. I don't know what's happening. And then somebody was like, well, that sounds like brain spotting. So I paid to talk to david grant Um, and david was like, yeah, that's exactly you discovered exactly what I discovered I was a brain spotting practice. I was an emdr practitioner working with shapiro shapiro said if you change my model You're not doing emdr
我说：“但他们要求我这样做。病人已经在EMDR里待了很久了。我做治疗师还没两个月。我不知道发生了什么。”然后有人说：“嗯，那听起来像脑点定位。”所以我付钱和David Grand谈了谈。David说：“是的，这正是你发现的，你发现的正是我的发现。”我是一个脑点定位实践者。我曾经是一名与Shapiro一起工作的EMDR从业者，Shapiro说：“如果你改变了我的模型，你就不是在做EMDR。”
and I noticed that Brain emdr was opening up every single brain spot a little bit So you were starting to get the person to feel every single issue that they had a small amount, but not going all the way to the bottom of any of them. And then I could surgically go in on these different spots that the eye associates with kind of stored trauma. And it sounds cranky. I mean, if I heard this, if I heard myself say this 10 years ago, it'd be like, I would have turned the podcast off. It took me being in the room with people who patients who I really loved and cared
我注意到EMDR正在一点一点地打开每一个脑点。所以你开始让那个人感觉到他们拥有的每一个问题的一小部分，但没有走到任何一个问题的底部。然后我可以手术般地进入眼睛与某种储存的创伤相关联的这些不同点。这听起来很疯狂。我的意思是，如果我10年前听到自己这么说，我会关掉播客。这需要我与我真正爱和关心的病人待在同一个房间里……
about and was desperate to help trying everything that I had finding this and it just worked, you know, and, and then it worked for me, I went to the training, I didn't get anything out of EMDR at my EMDR training, I went to the brain swatting training, dissociated for 20 minutes, you know, and had this huge profound experience that, you know, and had this huge profound experience that, you know, it was very helpful and also very humbling because it's not fun to realize how messed up we are, or it wasn't fun for me to realize that we need to. No, yeah, it's not.
并且渴望帮助他们，尝试了我拥有的一切，发现了这个，它就是有效。你知道，然后它对我有效。我去了培训，我在EMDR培训中什么也没得到，我去了脑点定位培训，解离了20分钟，你知道，有了这种巨大的深刻体验，这非常有帮助，也非常谦卑，因为意识到我们有多混乱并不好玩，或者意识到我们需要这样做对我来说并不好玩。不，是的，确实不好玩。
But I mean, I don't know. That's where the profound growth is though, because underneath our pain, we have such depth like all the pain trauma victims have been through is just the sign of a very expansive soul i think and like you're saying with the world i mean just the speed of the world right now i feel like it makes people feel gaslit and out of control and upset and you know all these things you did yeah yeah i mean we're being traumatized constantly and i i wish that there was better language because trauma is it's it's hard to come up with another word besides trauma but i really believe that we are but it is limiting and what
但我的意思是，我不知道。这就是深刻成长的地方，因为在我们的痛苦之下，我们有这样的深度。所有痛苦的创伤受害者所经历的，我认为只是一个非常广阔灵魂的标志。就像你说的世界，我的意思是，现在世界的速度，我觉得它让人感到被煤气灯效应（gaslit）操纵、失控和不安，你知道所有这些你做过的事情。是的，我的意思是，我们不断地受到创伤，我希望有更好的语言，因为创伤……很难想出除了创伤之外的另一个词，但我真的相信我们是……但这有限制性，而且……
kind of trauma are you talking about you know yeah but i really believe that we're like traumatized by various experiences in our society we like traumatized by various experiences in our society. We're traumatized by various experiences and then we're never able to come out of that fight or flight mode. So we're always in low key fight or flight mode and then being fed these traumas like people. Well, there's money in it. If the news is saying this group of people is going to come kill you and it has a big
你在谈论什么样的创伤？你知道，是的，但我真的相信我们就像被我们社会中的各种经历所创伤。我们被各种经历所创伤，然后我们永远无法从那种战斗或逃跑模式中走出来。所以我们总是处于低强度的战斗或逃跑模式，然后被喂食这些创伤，就像人们……好吧，这里面有钱可赚。如果新闻说这群人要来杀你，这对你的生活有很大影响。我的意思是，看看所有这些死人，死去的孩子。你需要……我不知道。这是肾上腺素。肾上腺素是能卖钱的东西。你知道，它会让我不断点击或阅读，或者任何能提高那个月指标的东西。我们已经让每个人的大脑都关闭了。每个人都处于战斗或逃跑状态。当你的前额叶皮层关闭时，你无法做出正常的决定。你无法做出关于你生活的基本决定。你无法……
bearing on your life. I mean, probably look at all these dead people, dead children. And you need to. And I, I don't. It's adrenaline. Adrenaline is what's going to sell. You know, it's going to keep me clicking or reading or, you know, whatever gets the metric up that month. We've gotten everybody's brains so shut down. Everyone's in fight or flight. And when your prefrontal cortex is shut down, you cannot make normal decisions. You can't make like basic decisions about your life. You can't
具体地思考事情，人们没有意识到这正在发生。就像人们在过着他们的生活，只是感到如此疲惫，他们没有意识到，不，你基本上处于急性创伤中，因为所有这些……我想我们只是……我认为技术的出现，它让我们面对的创伤比我们……比我们作为人类真正能够处理的要多得多。你知道，我们可能只关心半径10英里内的每个人，但除此之外，我们没有建立起关心的能力，我们没有能力关心全世界的每一个孩子，就像你关心一样。是的，我的意思是，那是真的，为每一个人哀悼。我不是那个意思，我不知道，这听起来太冷酷了，但我不是……就像你可以关心，但当我们被告知你需要关心……
concretely think about things and people don't realize that this is happening. It's like, you know, people are going about their lives, just feeling so frazzled and they don't realize that it's like, no, you're in acute trauma, basically, because of all this, you know, all the, I think we're just so, I think the advent of technology, it just puts in our face so much more trauma than we're ever, so much more, you know, in terms of current events and things like that, than we're actually meant to process as humans they're you know meant to care about everybody within a 10 mile radius of us maybe and then and like but outside of that it's like we don't you know we haven't like built up the capacity to we don't have the capacity to care about every single child in the whole world like you care yeah yeah i mean that is true and grieve every single person like i don't mean that in a hard hard line i don't know that sounds so cold but i don't it's like you can care but when we're told you need to care about
这里每天有20张死人的照片，你要像对待你认识的人一样去哀悼，然后你在情感上关闭了，因为你不能。是的，他们正在杀死……你知道，杀死狼，杀死雨林，所有这些……你在情感上关闭了，因为你无法感受到它。水平。但他们已经做了，你知道，我想，是的，你是对的。我的意思是，关心一组中的10个人是我们所做的。我们试图让大脑做所有它们没有被设计去做的事情。所以我们做得不完美。那种压力和焦虑必须去某个地方。它必须进入酒精或身体，或者什么是愤怒，你知道，但他们做过研究，住得离你越近的人，你认识的人就越少……
uh here are 20 pictures of dead people a day that you're supposed to grieve like they're people that you know and you shut down emotionally because you can't yeah they're killing the now you know killing the wolves and killing the rainforest and you know all these all these You shut down emotionally because you can't feel it. level. But they've done, you know, I think, yes, you're right. I mean, there's caring about 10 people kind of in a group is what we do. We're trying to make our brains do all this stuff that they're not designed to do. And so we're doing it imperfectly. And that stress and anxiety has to go somewhere. It has to go into alcohol or the body or to what is anger, you know, but like they've done studies and it's like, and the more people that live close to you, the less people, you know i mean somebody
住公寓的人不会认识他们的邻居，住在苏格兰农村的人会认识住在14英里外的人。哦，老本，你知道吗？是的，我们……当我想让我父亲回到爱尔兰去接触他的遗产什么的，我们试图找到最后一个亲戚，这有点黑暗，但我们去找了一个人，他们说：“哦，老本是那个认识所有人的人。”然后你在所有的农舍停下来。但我的意思是，你开车超过200英里。我不知道有多远，但它很大。
who has an apartment will not know their neighbor somebody who lives in rural scotland will know the person who lives 14 miles away oh old ben did you know yeah we were like we when my dad wanted to go back to ireland to encounter his um heritage or whatever and we're like trying to find the last relative and uh it's kind of dark but like we went to one guy and they're like, oh, old Ben is the one that knows all the people. And then you stop at all these farmhouses. But I mean, you're driving over 200 miles. I don't know how long it was, but it's huge.
花了一整天。路又慢又弯。所以距离可能没那么大。但这个人认识所有人，能告诉你任何事情。你知道，我们最终到达了那个镇，最后一个……你知道，我不记得名字了，不是Blackstock什么的，最后一个应该是那个地方，他们说：“哦，他昨晚喝了太多威士忌，掉进火里烧死了，你应该早一周来。”那就像，“哦，不。你是认真的吗？”哦，天哪，是的。什么？
It took all day long. The roads are slow and curvy. So it probably wasn't that huge of a distance. But this guy knew everybody and could tell you whatever and you know we finally ended up in the town where the last um you know i don't remember the name it wasn't blackstock or whatever the last one was supposed to be and they were like oh he drank too much whiskey last night and he fell into the fire and burned up you should have come a week ago that was like, oh no. Are you serious? Oh Lord, yes. What?
那是那个人说的。那是个好故事。总之，创伤。它意味着什么？抱歉。我不知道。不，我知道。我只是……你知道。
That was what the guy said. That's a good story. Anyway, drama. What does it mean? I'm sorry. I don't know. No, I know. I'm just, you know.
是的，但是的，你周围的人越多，你认识的人就越少。我们开始筑墙来保护自己。所以这些被淹没的新闻，让人们一直处于恐慌状态是有利可图的。但这会对社会、对孩子在长期内造成什么影响？对。让每个人……我不知道，我正要说“愚蠢”，我儿子在幼儿园，我不知道你的女儿，你女儿也在幼儿园，但我儿子说：“别说愚蠢。”他们在学校因为说“愚蠢”而惹上麻烦，我正试图不说“愚蠢”，这就是它的意思，但在学校别那样说是一回事。
Yeah, but yeah, the more people that are around you, the less people you know. And we start to build these walls to protect ourselves. And so this inundated news stuff, it's profitable to keep people panicked all the time. But what does that do to society, to kids over a long period of time? Right. Makes everybody... I don't know my i was about to say stupid and my son is in kindergarten i don't know if your daughter your daughter's in kindergarten too but my son's like don't say stupid and they get in trouble for saying stupid in school and i'm trying to not say stupid and this is what that means but don't say that at school is something.
是的，他总是对我尖叫，我的父母。Beanie，别说愚蠢。是的，但像脑点定位。对。好的，所以我认为让我兴奋的是，它不像EMDR，就像你说的，你不需要在工作之前把所有东西都变成语言。就像我……我所经历的是，我总是进入这种感觉，几乎像表演焦虑，当你……你知道，有人问我，当你问我：“你在想什么，或者你想处理什么？”然后我就一片空白。我认为，这就像……我总是……
Yeah, he's always screaming at me and my my parents. Beanie, don't say stupid. Yeah, but like brain spotting. Right. OK, so I it's I think what's what i'm excited about is that it's um it's unlike emdr like you're saying you don't have to put everything into words before you can work on it um like i have this i the what i experience is i always go into this it feels like performance anxiety almost like when you're when you know somebody's asking me like when you're, when, you know, somebody's asking me, like when you're asking me like, okay, what are you thinking about or what do you want to work on? And then I just go blank. And I think that, and it's like, I always,
我总是把那归因于“好吧，那只是我”。我说这些是我的问题等等。但我认为这就像一个大的……我认为这是创伤幸存者常见的事情，就像你被推到风口浪尖：“告诉我，你亲密地，你脑子里在想什么？”然后你的解离就像被立即触发了。所以这很有帮助，当你说：“好的，这里我可以找到一个脑点并处理它，让我们看看会发生什么。”这对我来说很有帮助。我觉得这实际上非常具有欺骗性的强大，能够说：“我不知道……”
I always like attributed that to just like, okay, that's just me. And I'm like, these are my issues and blah, blah, blah. But I think that that is like a big, I think that that's a common thing with trauma survivors is like you're put on the spot like tell me you're intimate what's on your brain and then you it's like your dissociation just is like triggered immediately and so it's helpful it's helpful for me when you're like okay here i can just find find a brain spot and work with it and let's see what comes of that. Like that, I feel like really, actually very deceptively powerful to be able to be like, I don't know
我在想什么。因为就像，我不知道我在想什么。然后我恐慌。然后就像，我可以……就像创伤，我不知道，你知道，创伤，感觉就在那里，就像：“好的，我要哭了。”因为我……现在我很尴尬，因为我想不出该说什么。而且我永远无法想出我的创伤是什么，以便能够为自己辩护。你知道，它触发了所有这些恐惧，但没有一个我能用语言表达，因为我只是进入了冻结状态。这就是……战斗、逃跑。嗯，这就是创伤让你不知道出了什么问题，你觉得一切都出了问题，所以你很多时候不记得把你带到那里的事件，或者事件，或者你的时期。但你坐在那里觉得：“我不喜欢新闻上的那个。”“哦，服务员没注意我。”就像你试图把焦虑附加到所有这些能解释它的事情上，然后这让你精疲力竭，而且这让周围的人……
what I'm thinking. Cause it's like, I don't know what I'm thinking. And then I, then I panic. And then it's like, I could, it's like the trauma, I don't know, you know, trauma, the feelings are there like, okay, I'm going to cry. Cause I so, now I'm embarrassed because I can't think of what to say. And like, I'm never going to be able to think of what my trauma is to be able to advocate for myself. You know, it like triggers all these, all these fears, but none of which I can put into words because I just go like freeze. It's that, you know, fight, flight. Well, and that's the thing is trauma makes you not know what is wrong you feel like everything's wrong and so you don't remember the event a ton of the time they got you there or events or your period but you're sitting there being like i don't like that on
很多时候对那种行为感到厌倦。是的，但你只是试图把你的身体所持有的这种环境焦虑附加到那件事上，以找出问题所在。是的，他们和治疗师谈论得更多，是的，创造新的神经通路连接到你的创伤，所以你只是比以前更概括化了你的创伤。这说得通，就像你觉得当我们以某种方式创造这些与语言结构的任意连接时，当语言还没有到来时……语言是一个工具，它是一种适应。
the news oh well the waiter didn't pay attention to me this like you're trying to attach the anxiety all these things that would explain it and then that's exhausting you and it's driving the people around you um you know to to be tired of that behavior a lot of the time yeah and but you're just trying to attach this ambient anxiety that your body's holding to the thing to figure out what the problem is and yeah they're talking about it more with the therapist yeah creating new neural pathways connecting to your trauma so you're just generalizing your trauma even more than it was before that makes sense like you just feel like when we're creating these arbitrary connections to language structures in certain ways when language isn't already coming like language is a tool it's an adaptation
但如果东西还没有进入语言，我认为很多时候这会结晶化它。这就是我……我只是对所有这些东西的精神层面非常感兴趣。这就像保持它……好吧，我不知道。我不会真正深入那个，但是……嗯，我的意思是，我们可能不想让你待太久，但有另一个联合主持人真是太好了。但我的意思是，也许有一种说法是，你知道，我们有那个前额叶皮层虚无主义的自我大脑，即你只是你所做的、你能看到的、尝到的、触摸到的、闻到的、完成的。然后我们有这种神秘的皮层下大脑，它是……你知道，精神上的，如果过度放纵可能是近视的，或者有点孩子气，但也许有幼稚的风险。从它的角度来看，
but if it's if stuff is not already in language i think a lot of the time that can chris it crystallizes it this is this where i, I've just gotten so into kind of the spiritual aspect of all that stuff. And it just like keeping it, well, I don't know. I won't get into that really, but. Well, I mean, and we, we probably don't want to keep you too long, but it's wonderful to have another co-host but i mean maybe like one way of saying that is that you know we've got that prefrontal cortex nihilistic ego brain of you are only what you do what you can see taste touch smell accomplish and then um we have this kind of mystical subcortical brain that is you know spiritual maybe myopic if it's overindulged or kind of childlike but maybe at the risk of being childish. And from its perspective,
你知道，我们都是相连的，一切都是禅宗般的体验。我们非常多地是我们所感受到的。而另一个是，我们只是我们所做的。那些自我碎片并不真的想在同一个脑袋里，你知道吗？治疗模型之间的许多争斗都归结于此。我认为最好的模型为容纳两者留出了空间。你在常青的语言中看到了这一点，比如阿德勒说：“嗯，这是对内部大东西的补偿，在外面。”内部有一个大东西。
you know, we're all connected and everything is the Zen-like experience. And we are what we feel very much. Whereas the other one is we are only what we do. And those pieces of self don't really want to be in the same head, you know? So much of the fights between therapy models come back to that. And I think the best models make room to hold both. And you see that in a perennial language, like Adler says, well, it's compensation for everything on big on the inside there on the outside. There's a big thing on the inside.
荣格说对立面的张力。而且，我认为弗洛伊德的心理学在描述弗洛伊德自己的心理学方面非常好。是的。抱歉。我想说好老弗洛伊德。
And Jung says the tension of the opposites. And, you know, I think Freud's psychology was very good at describing Freud's own psychology. Yeah. Sorry. I think good old Freud.
是的。但是的，我不知道这是否有帮助，但这正是我的看法，给人们做这两件事的许可，因为人们觉得：“嗯，我不能感受，那是不负责任的，我知道所有这些东西都是真的，所以我不能感受那个。”就像：“不，也许你知道，你也犯过错误，但你仍然对这个人犯错感到生气，生气是可以的，你不会告诉他们。”你知道，是的，或者你知道，那个人只想感受，而你不得不说：“是的，我的意思是，你也许有最纯洁的心，但你仍然必须……准时上班，否则你可能会被解雇。”那是真实的，你知道，如果我是世界之王，我会改变那个，但我不是。你知道，我们不能凭直觉消除这个。是的，不，我不想……
Yeah. Yeah. But yeah, I i i don't know if that is is helpful but and that's kind of what i see is giving people permission to do both because people feel like well i can't feel that's irresponsible i know all this stuff's true so i can't feel that and it's like no maybe you know you've made mistakes too but you're still mad that this person made a mistake it's okay to be mad you're not gonna tell them you know yeah um or you know that the person only wants to feel and you're having to say yeah i mean you you maybe have the purest heart ever but you still have to you know be at work on time or you're probably gonna get fired that's that's real you know if i was king of the world that changed that i'm not you know we can't intuit this away yeah no i don't
做那份工作。但是的，我不知道，我们迫不及待地想和你一起工作，太兴奋了。在脑点定位培训之后，我们还得做另一集，关于你的体验和一切，因为那是我们收到的最大的问题之一。我一直在写那封邮件或给州外的提供者打电话，他们说：“你说脑点定位。我很感兴趣。我怎么做？我在哪里做？”
want that job um but uh yeah i don't we can't wait to work with you it's so excited uh and we'll have to do another episode after the brain spawning training uh kind of about what your experience with it was and everything because that's one of the biggest questions that we get. I'm like writing that email or having a phone call for providers out of the state all the time where they're like, you said brain spotting. I'm interested. How do I do it? Where do I do it?
它是什么样的？所以可能有一个……如果我必须和人们开同样的会议，你知道，10次、20次，我通常会说……
What's it like? So probably having a, if I, if I have to have the same meeting with people, you know, 10, 20 times, I usually am like,
我想拍一个播客或视频来讨论这个话题，这样我就能直接发给你。然后，但是的，我相信这会很有趣。你和谁签约了，或者你和谁一起做？这样我就能直接发给你，然后你可以听。但是的，我相信这会很有趣。你和谁签约了，或者你和谁一起做？这是一个很好的问题。我不记得她的名字了。她在亚特兰大。
I want to shoot a podcast or a video on this topic so that I can just send you that. And then, but yeah, I'm sure it'll be interesting. Who did you sign up with or who are you doing it with? so that I can just send you that and then you can listen to it. But yeah, I'm sure it'll be interesting. Who did you sign up with or who are you doing it with? That is a great question. I can't remember her name. She's in Atlanta.
Cynthia Schwartzberg？听起来很熟悉。她在亚特兰大。那就是做我那个的人。那是一次很好的交易。好的，我不记得了，我会告诉你，我昨天确实收到了我的书和指针。哦，是的，他们看到了。是的，我希望他们能给你寄他的书和ETT，因为ETT培训……当你读那本书时，它真的打开了很多，但他们没有。脑点定位给你寄David的书……
Cynthia Schwartzberg? That sounds familiar. She's in Atlanta. That's who did mine. It was a good trade. Okay, I can't remember i'll tell you i did get my book and my pointer in the mail there yesterday oh yeah they see yeah i wish they would send you his book with ett because the ett training like you really like it opens up so much when you read the book but they don't the brain spotting sending you david's book
之前，这很好。是的，我很兴奋能看看它。还有什么你想告诉人们关于你的实践，或者只是作为介绍说一下吗？我真的很高兴我们这里有了另一个声音，因为人们不只是听我一个人说可能很好。是的，这很有趣。嗯，是的，我不……我的意思是，没什么特别的。我的意思是，现在就像：“好的，我不知道怎么用语言表达，Joel。”不，我……我有很多关于我观点变化的事情很难用语言表达，这与创伤的影响有关，真的炸开了你大脑中与某种东西相连的部分。我真的想到像集体潜意识，关于像那样的事情，以及……在创伤中有精神体验的人，就像……
before it's nice yeah yeah i have i'm i'm excited to look at it. Is there like anything else you want to like tell people about your practice or just kind of say as an introduction? And I'm really happy that we've got another, you know, voice on here because it's probably nice for people to not just hear me go blind. Yeah, this is fun. um yeah i don't i mean not in particular i mean now it's like okay i don't know how to put it into language joel no i um i i there's a lot that i that is hard to put into language about about the changes in my perspective that have everything to do with um kind of the effects of trauma really blowing up the parts of your brain that are connected to something like a i really think about like the collective unconscious like about things like that and um and people who have spiritual experiences with trauma, like that
这对那些根本不精神，或者不像我这样不信教的人来说，经历与创伤相关的深刻精神体验是非常普遍的。这似乎在提供者中发生得越来越多。就像我知道很多提供者只是坚持这种非常理性的观点、科学的观点。然后突然之间，他们遇到了一种给他们这种超验体验的疗法，他们感到谦卑，你知道，
is, it's extremely common for people who aren't spiritual at all, or aren't religious like me, to have, to experience spiritual, like a profoundly spiritual experience with, associated with trauma. That seems to be happening more and more to providers. Like I know so many providers that are just kind of clung to this very kind of rational perspective, scientific perspective. And then all of a sudden they are, they encountered some kind of therapy that gives them this transcendental experience and they kind of feel humbled, you know,
以一种方式与他们的另一部分坐在一起，你知道，无论哪一部分被压抑了，另一部分都会呼唤你。是的。因为我从来没有……我一直对哲学非常感兴趣，但我一直认为自己是无神论者。所以这只是，我认为它是……但我意识到它确实非常谦卑。然后我意识到，我们扔掉的很多东西，比如精神病，那不是真的。我们并不真正知道那意味着什么。这只是像这样一个类别：“好的，我们不明白那个人在说什么。所以我们只是称之为精神病。”
in a way to sit with this other part of them, you know, whatever part is repressed, the other part calls to you. Yes. Cause I've never been, I've always been very interested in like philosophy, but I've, I've always identified as an atheist. And so it was just, I think it's, um, but I, it made me realize like it is very humbling. And then I've kind of realized that a lot of the things that we just throw away is that psychosis, that's not real. And we don't really know what that means. It's just like this category of like, okay, we don't understand what that person's talking about. So we're just going to call it psychosis.
以一种方式去接纳他们内心那部分的自我，你知道，无论哪部分被压抑了，另一部分都会在呼唤你。是的。因为我从未……我一直对哲学很感兴趣，但我一直认为自己是无神论者。所以这只是……我想，嗯，但这让我意识到，这真的很让人谦卑。然后我意识到，我们随手抛弃的很多东西，比如所谓的“精神病”，那并不是真实的。我们并不真正理解那意味着什么。那就像是一个分类，比如，“好吧，我们听不懂那个人在说什么，所以我们就把它称为精神病。”
But there's so many, our DNA is capable of, I mean, our bodies are capable of so much more than we. Well, the ego wants to be all we are. You know, it's very threatening to the prefrontal cortex language and time sensing brain to say, what if there's this whole other part of me? Yeah. Just by itself, just by its nature, it has to kind of protect itself from that. Yeah. I think I stuff like i realized or i've
但其实我们的DNA能做到的，我的意思是，我们的身体能做到的远比我们想象的多。嗯，自我（ego）想要成为我们的一切。你知道，对于前额叶皮层这种负责语言和时间感知的脑区来说，如果说“如果我还有另一个完全不同的部分呢？”，这会带来很大的威胁。是的。它本身，就其本质而言，必须以某种方式保护自己免受这种影响。是的。我想我意识到或者我已经
learned in our society we do everything that like and calcifies like the pineal gland in our brain our pineal gland is connected to circadian rhythms and in our connection to something that feels spiritual like meaning and things like that and um our society we really suppress the pineal gland's ability to connect to it has crystals in it that um piezoelectric crystals that hook into yeah it transmits your brain waves um this is real not it's not it's like real neuroscience um that we just kind of ignore it's like something that it's like okay well we know that the pineal gland does something in this realm and it makes people feel like they're god and then we just throw it then it's like but there's not a god so there's not there's nothing beyond humans but any but so many people
了解到在我们的社会中，我们所做的一切似乎都在让大脑中的松果体钙化。我们的松果体与昼夜节律有关，也与我们对某种精神层面的连接有关，比如意义感之类的东西。嗯，我们的社会确实抑制了松果体连接的能力，它里面有晶体，嗯，压电晶体，可以连接到……是的，它能传输你的脑电波。这是真实的，这不是……这是真正的神经科学，只是我们忽略了它。就像是，好吧，我们知道松果体在这个领域确实有某种作用，它让人感觉自己像神一样，然后我们就把它抛弃了，就像是“但并没有神，所以人类之外什么都没有”。但是，有太多的人
have these spiritual experiences and are trying to integrate them and reconcile them with things that have happened and i think think it's like honoring people, where people are and what they're- Yeah, wherever they are. That they're mulling over things that are turning around in their heads. To honor people's experiences is like, you're not going crazy that you are feeling like you're,
有这些精神体验，并试图整合它们，将它们与已经发生的事情调和起来。我认为这就像是尊重人们，尊重他们所处的位置，以及他们正在……是的，无论他们处于什么状态。他们正在脑海中反复思考这些事情。尊重人们的体验就像是说，你并没有疯，你感觉到的……
yeah, you're not going crazy to suddenly feel like you're having spiritual experiences this is normal for trauma populations and we're not quite sure what it means but we can work with it just like just like you know we're not sure what depression means but we can but we work with it you know we can identify markers for depression but we really don't you know like you're saying that it's it's all kind of a metaphor like what is self-esteem it's a lumping symptoms together to say maybe enough of these boxes being checked is this thing that we can label um yeah it's steven dr stephen vasquez that did the ett training for me was saying during one of the things that on the light device and some of the um things that are more likely to give you a transcendental experience to treat
是的，你并没有疯，突然感觉到自己有了精神体验，这对创伤人群来说是很正常的。我们不太确定这意味着什么，但我们可以处理它，就像……就像你知道的，我们不确定抑郁症意味着什么，但我们确实在处理它。你知道，我们可以识别抑郁症的标志，但我们真的不……你知道，就像你说的，这一切都是一种隐喻。什么是自尊？这只是把症状归纳在一起，说也许勾选了足够多的这些框，就是我们可以贴上标签的这个东西。嗯，是的，是史蒂文，史蒂芬·瓦斯奎兹博士，他为我做了ETT培训，他在其中一个环节提到，在光设备和一些更容易让你产生超越体验以治疗
deeper trauma than a ton of the people are like I'm an atheist but I just talked to my dead wife and I don't know what that was but thank you I feel better and I but it doesn't change and he's like okay that's fine I'm not trying to change your mind I was raised in the Episcopal church which in Alabama is kind of mystical and I think I liked about the Episcopal church growing up not every church is like that not every Episcopal church growing up, not every church is like that. Not every Episcopal church is like that, but the ones that I encountered, people kind of agreed that it was more important to get along and to love each other than to agree on everything.
更深层创伤的事情上，很多人会说“我是无神论者，但我刚刚和死去的妻子谈过话，我不知道那是什么，但谢谢你，我感觉好多了”。但这并没有改变什么，他说“好吧，没关系，我不是要改变你的想法”。我是在圣公会教堂长大的，在阿拉巴马州，这有点神秘色彩。我想我喜欢成长过程中的圣公会教堂，并不是每个教堂都这样，不是每个成长过程中的圣公会教堂都这样，不是每个教堂都这样。不是每个圣公会教堂都这样，但我遇到的那些，人们似乎都同意，相处融洽和彼此相爱比在所有事情上达成一致更重要。
And so there were people who were incredibly literal believers, you know, and then there were people who were very, I mean, essentially they're atheists that believes in community and coming here and that you're, you know, working on this greater project and making the world better.
所以有些人是极其字面意义上的信徒，你知道，然后有些人非常……我的意思是，本质上他们是相信社区、来到这里并认为你正在……你知道，致力于这个更伟大的项目并让世界变得更美好的无神论者。
And then there are people kind of in the middle that liked metaphor of it and think, you know, I don't know, like it just, and people went there. I mean, the point was that this was a good thing. We're doing it because it's good. We don't all have to sit down and figure out exactly what it, what we believe perfectly. I mean, there's some, you know, theology in the Catholic, in the, in the Episccopal church but usually like um when you go through um you call it uh confirmation or whatever the classes are them being like this is what baptists think this is what catholics think you can take whatever you they're like them reviewing the theology was that it was it was pretty loose that's how that's how i grew up in the episcopal church church as well. And that's also.
然后中间还有一些人喜欢它的隐喻，认为，你知道，我不知道，就像它只是……人们去了那里。我的意思是，重点是这是一件好事。我们这样做是因为它是好的。我们不必都坐下来完美地弄清楚我们到底相信什么。我的意思是，天主教、圣公会教堂里有一些神学，但通常当你进行……你称之为坚信礼或者任何课程时，他们会说“这是浸信会教徒的想法，这是天主教徒的想法”，你可以采纳任何你……他们回顾神学时，那是相当宽松的。我就是在圣公会教堂长大的。这也是。
My line in therapy is always just like, I'm a therapist, not a priest. You know, I can let you go through it and make room for it, but I don't know why. You know, and my why is not your why. That's the fine line where it's like, all of a sudden I am thinking about these spiritual concepts, but I've always been so turned off and very offended by therapists who bring their own religion into therapy and bring their own. Especially without asking. There's some people that say, are you a Christian or are you a Christian in this way? Can we pray? And the patient feels safer. I've had patients that had that experience, but when you're just bringing it in because you think that's right, I feel like that's disrespectful.
我在治疗中的原则总是像，我是治疗师，不是牧师。你知道，我可以让你经历它并为它腾出空间，但我不知道为什么。你知道，我的“为什么”不是你的“为什么”。那是一条微妙的界限，就像突然间我开始思考这些精神概念，但我一直对那些把自己的宗教带入治疗并带来……的治疗师感到非常反感和冒犯。尤其是没有询问的情况下。有些人会说，你是基督徒吗？或者你是这样信仰的基督徒吗？我们可以祈祷吗？病人会感到更安全。我遇到过有这种经历的病人，但当你只是因为你认为那是对的而把它带进来时，我觉得那是不尊重的。
Yeah. Yeah. It doesn't allow room for people to. I mean, it's kind of the, I don't know, the levels of our psyche that really need to be restructured are these deep, deep seated beliefs, which relate to spirituality and things like that. And when you come in as a therapist and say, well, this is the basic framework of what we're, of the truth of everything. And now let's do therapy. You're really missing, you're missing the really good work that you can do, which is like really going back in and, and helping people to structure and like re-story, like what is my basic experience of life?
是的。是的。它没有给人们留出空间。我的意思是，这有点像……我不知道，我们真正需要重构的心理层面是这些根深蒂固的信念，它们与灵性之类的事情有关。当你作为治疗师进来并说“好吧，这是我们关于万物真理的基本框架，现在让我们开始治疗”时，你真的错过了，你错过了你可以做的真正好的工作，那就是真正回到过去，帮助人们构建和重构故事，比如“我对生活的基本体验是什么？”
What is my basic, what are my basic beliefs or not even beliefs, but just like the way that I am in the world and who I am. Yeah. I mean, identity is a relationship between the self and the body and the world in this way that, you know, what is it? David T self and the body in the world in this way that you know what is it david tacy uh had a talk to the sydney australia young society and he was saying like um self is not a destination it is a process it is a process of you trying to contain the collective unconscious and hold on to an ego you know but this it is moving back and forth between these things yeah yeah it's a process
我基本的……我基本的信念是什么，或者甚至不是信念，只是我在世界上的方式以及我是谁。是的。我的意思是，身份是自我、身体和世界之间的一种关系，你知道，它是……大卫·泰西在悉尼澳大利亚荣格协会的一次演讲中说，自我不是目的地，它是一个过程。它是你试图容纳集体潜意识并坚持自我的过程，你知道，但它是在这些事物之间来回移动。是的，是的，这是一个过程。
it's we're in we're in times time space and require everything be a process if you're in the quantum field it doesn't have to be a process but where we are you have to go through the motions and we have to you know we do have a physical brain that needs that you know we can there are ways to restructure it really quickly that we're learning about, but it's still, you have to move some stuff around physically. Like there's going to be process around the changes that need to happen in order for you to be come actualized or transcend this reality. And I really believe that people can. We don't, in Western society, we don't acknowledge enlightenment and transcendence and actualization as being real. When people come to therapy for different reasons, some patients, that's never going to be part of
它是……我们处于时间空间中，要求一切都是一个过程。如果你在量子场中，它不必是一个过程，但在我们所处的地方，你必须经历这些动作，我们必须……你知道，我们确实有一个需要那个的物理大脑，你知道，我们可以……有办法非常快地重构它，我们正在学习，但它仍然……你必须在物理上移动一些东西。就像为了让你实现自我或超越这个现实，需要发生的改变周围会有过程。我真的相信人们可以。在西方社会，我们不承认启蒙、超越和自我实现是真实的。当人们因为不同的原因来寻求治疗时，有些病人，那永远不会成为
their thing. They just want to quit biting their nails, you know, and I can do that too. You know, come back if you, come back when you want to do something else. Yeah. It's lovely to see people who just, who just need help biting to quit biting their nails. Although that's very, that's very difficult to do. I, I was as a,
他们的事情的一部分。他们只是想戒掉咬指甲的习惯，你知道，我也可以做到。你知道，如果你想做别的事情，再回来。是的。看到那些只需要帮助戒掉咬指甲习惯的人，真是太好了。虽然这非常，这非常困难。我，我曾经是一个……
as a nail biter from when I was little, it's very difficult, difficult to break that, break that. It is. Well, I thank you so much for getting on today. And,
从小就咬指甲的人，要改掉这个习惯非常困难。确实。好吧，非常感谢你今天能来。而且，
um, we have Alice's page. We'll go live on our website soon if it's not up already. Well, I thank you so much for getting on today. And we have Alice's page will go live on our website soon if it's not up already. So if stuff going um but um it could be you know see this next month definitely not longer than than three months so okay we'll see we'll see where we end up but if you want to get on the waitlist for alice um we our waitlist is like i don't even know where it is now i need to ask lily but it went it was out like a year and a half and so hopefully it'll really move now and this would be the time to to call since a lot of times um just when you have a new therapist that's starting full-time and has no patients apparently that's a good time to load me up yeah no i'm really excited that your practice is so cool. I'm totally. It's our practice.
嗯，我们有爱丽丝的页面。如果还没上线，很快就会在我们网站上发布。好吧，非常感谢你今天能来。我们有爱丽丝的页面，如果还没上线，很快就会在我们网站上发布。所以如果事情进展……但……可能是，你知道，下个月见，绝对不会超过三个月，所以好吧，我们会看看最终结果如何。但如果你想加入爱丽丝的候补名单，我们……我们的候补名单现在在哪里我甚至不知道，我需要问莉莉，但它已经排到一年半以后了，所以希望现在能有所进展。现在是打电话的好时机，因为很多时候，当你有一位全职开始工作且没有病人的新治疗师时，显然那是让我忙起来的好时机。是的，不，我真的很兴奋你的诊所这么酷。我完全……这是我们的诊所。
It's not. It's collective. It's everybody's. Yeah. You bring later. Well, that's the spirit of the practice. And that's what you're doing is really. Y'all are doing really cool work.
不是。它是集体的。它是大家的。是的。你稍后带来。嗯，这就是诊所的精神。而你正在做的确实是……你们正在做非常酷的工作。
Yeah. And I can't. I can't wait for you to meet everybody because it is a cool community. And I'm really looking forward to you getting started. And now that Peak is established and just kind of taking time to be a community again and actually sit down and run cases because it's been a hairy six, seven months. Yeah. For me, it's just been just 13-hour days, you know, I do therapy for half of it. And then the other stuff adds up.
是的。我迫不及待地想让你见到大家，因为这是一个很酷的社区。我真的很期待你开始工作。现在Peak已经建立起来了，只是花时间再次成为一个社区，并真正坐下来处理案例，因为这六七个月真是太艰难了。是的。对我来说，只是13个小时的工作日，你知道，我有一半时间在做治疗。然后其他事情加起来。
But it's a nice community. I mean, I'm proud of our practice i feel like um i mean one you know people make more than they would have individually which is important to me um and then two like we all kind of have a voice in a place and have made something better together than we could have individually definitely better than i could have made by myself with all you guys so i don't know that's neat though that was always what i wanted to do since i was a kid is somehow have community you know and um and always want to be a therapist and it's it's a new thing but it's scary it's when we were moving you in though i was realizing like we're pretty far along in this thing like i tend to think it pretty new but you were asking like how many rooms was tap rude and it's like wow this is actually practice now i know i know like that um and yeah just a
但这是一个很好的社区。我的意思是，我为我们的诊所感到自豪。我觉得……我的意思是，第一，你知道，人们赚的比他们单独工作时多，这对我来说很重要。第二，我们都有发言权，有一个地方，并且一起创造了一些比我们单独能创造的更好的东西。绝对比我一个人带着你们所有人能创造的要好。所以我不知道，这很棒。这是我从小就一直想做的事情，就是以某种方式拥有社区，你知道，而且一直想成为一名治疗师。这是一个新事物，但很可怕。当我们搬进来时，我意识到我们在这件事上已经走得很远了。我倾向于认为它很新，但你问过Tap Rude有多少个房间，就像“哇，这现在真的是个诊所了”。我知道，我知道，就像那个……是的，只是
few months ago i was very much like i don't think i'm gonna be a therapist anymore i was like trying to figure out how i relate to the field and everything. And I'm very excited about being able to move in a direction that actually feels authentic. I didn't know. I'm just, I'm really excited about working with y'all. Well, we're excited to work with you.
几个月前，我非常觉得“我不认为我还能做治疗师了”。我当时在试图弄清楚我如何与这个领域建立联系等等。我非常兴奋能够朝着一个真正感觉真实的方向前进。我不知道。我只是，我真的很兴奋能和你们一起工作。好吧，我们也很兴奋能和你一起工作。
My new clients. I'm so excited to meet everybody. Yeah. Well, thanks so much, Alice. I appreciate it. And yeah,
我的新客户。我太兴奋能见到大家了。是的。好吧，非常感谢，爱丽丝。我很感激。而且是的，
get therapy, Birmingham.com again, that's get therapy. Birmingham.com is where you would find more information if you're local um and if you want to subscribe to the podcast or check out the youtube that's where you do it um thank you all so much and you know reach out for for anything awesome thank you Come say you might go crazy Then again it might make you go insane There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
get therapy, Birmingham.com，再说一遍，get therapy. Birmingham.com是你如果身处本地想了解更多信息的地方。如果你想订阅播客或查看YouTube，那就是你要去的地方。非常感谢大家，你知道，有任何事情随时联系。太棒了，谢谢。去说你可能会疯掉。话又说回来，它可能会让你发疯。这个剧集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。